Hello,
beautiful people with the Internet.
It's time to party again.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
They have this episode of the podcast
brought to you by stamps.com.
A super easy and convenient way to ship
things.
If you have a business,
if you do things out of your home or do
things out of your office,
you can print.
Why does this sound weird?
Something sound weird and weird.
Yeah.
There's some,
I think it's just the headphone.
Oh,
there goes.
The Jack just wasn't um,
with stamps.com.
You can print us postage for any package
or letter right from your desk.
Super easy to do.
You can use the digital scale that they
provide with our free offer.
If you go to stamps.com,
click on the microphone in the upper
right hand corner and entering the code
word j r e you will get a $110 bonus
offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to
$55 of free postage.
It is the way Brian sends all of his t
shirts.
When you go to [inaudible] dot tv,
those sweet kitty cat.
Do you have a new one now?
I know you're far with new ones.
She's us.
Louisa,
Ladies and gentlemen,
go there.
Waste some money.
I spend,
uh,
enjoy.
Purchase.
Um,
this is one of the new ones.
That blue one.
Is that a concept or is that one of the.
All the new ones are concepts I'm at.
I'm creating a whole new store.
It's gonna be a big store and all these
new ones are test products that I'm
seeing how the manufacturers are and all
of them will be set with stamps.com.
It's the fucking easiest way to send
anything through the mail.
You don't have to fuck with the post
office.
You do it all from your desk,
whether your desk at your office or your
desk at home,
what we all that stuff out.
Put the postage on and printed up from a
regular computer.
Slap it on the box and hand it to the
postman and your diggity diggity done.
It's so easy to do.
And again,
use the code word j r e and you get this
$110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to
$55 a free postage,
avoid time consuming trips to the post
office and you can save up to 80 percent
compared to a postage meter,
a postage meters the way businesses used
to do this,
uh,
and it's a huge pain in the ass.
It's expensive and there's multiyear
commitments and hidden fees,
but stamps.com
eliminates all that mess and nonsense
and allows you to do the exact same
thing from your home computer.
And again,
use a code word jr even when you click
on the microphone in the upper right
hand corner and get your $110 bonus
offer.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com.
That's o n n I t a human optimization
website.
What we try to do it on a.com
is,
look,
I'm a big fan of supplements.
Some people aren't and I completely and
totally understand that.
If you're curious though about
supplements and curious of the benefits
of supplements,
I believe that the benefits are
substantial,
especially if you pay attention to.
I mean,
there's always going to be weird fat
loss claims.
If you guys seen all this shit with Dr
Oz,
Dr Oz's fuck dude,
he's bought.
They brought that guy in front of
Congress.
They brought him in.
That's not good son because he's a liar.
He's a.
he's a creepy liar saying he's got
miracle cures and these little berries
that they make pills out of,
they give him kickbacks.
Doctors are human beings,
ladies and gentlemen,
and sometimes doctors do creepy shit and
that is a creepy fuck.
The fat thing to me is it's insidious.
It's extra creepy because people like
the fat thing is a self esteem thing.
It's a discipline thing.
It's a health thing.
There's so much connected to fat.
It's like,
to me,
it drives me more nutty than people that
are claiming the making your dick bigger
because that's just so stupid.
If you bought big Dick Pills,
he's just an idiot,
you know,
but the fat thing is like,
God,
you're sad and you're just thinking,
if I could just get rid of all this
extra me,
it's the porn of vitamins and
supplements though that sells the most
of any other thing that you'll ever see.
That's why they always have like
celebrities like Anna Nicole Smith,
Dr Phil and all that,
stuff like that.
Or I may not.
Dr Ross and I'm sure Dr Phil does salt
you need to do to make your relationship
birders lose some fucking white.
You've got to wonder what it is about a
doctor getting on TV as well.
Like,
yeah,
that is true.
I was talking to,
I'm a researcher,
a friend of mine from up in Canada and
he said,
you always have to know it was his take
on it,
that there becomes an issue.
Even with like super intelligent people
when you become a celebrity when you
were a celebrity doctor,
when you're a celebrity astronomer,
where your celebrity,
whatever,
that there's the pitfalls of fame that
fall into that and the monetary benefits
of twisting information.
In one way or another,
like,
like with Dr Oz is doing,
he's obviously getting paid by these
companies.
Say that they have these fat pills,
but he's so stupid,
man.
They asked him,
would you say that a pill is a miracle?
You know,
and he's like,
no.
Well I,
you know,
I took the word miracle.
I'm,
you certainly couldn't say a miracle in
terms of you sat miracle on your show.
You fuckhead more than one.
They showed a John Stewart or that other
guy,
the new guy on Hbo,
who's The new guy in Israel with the
glasses.
John Oliver.
I trust people with English accent and
glasses implicitly.
Immediately trust those guys.
But he's really good at his shows.
Really good.
And he did a fantastic thing breaking
down what a scumbag.
Dr Oz's,
you know,
sometimes you see those infomercials
where there'll be a doctor who will
vouch for something that's happening
there.
You almost wonder if there shouldn't be
some kind of regulation,
if that's some kind of abuse of their
position in society or something.
Well you,
it's abusive.
And here's one of the more insidious
things about it.
The real raw,
real problem is there are things out
there that can benefit you,
but the only way to find out is to get
things that have been backed by science,
double blind,
placebo controlled tests,
things that have been done where you
know for sure and getting back to on it,
all the stuff that we sell is stuff that
we,
there's,
there's a history of human use,
it goes back a long time and there's a
research pages on every one of the
supplements and supplements are just a
part of what we sell it on it,
but I think that supplements can give
you things that you're just not going to
get from your diet when it comes to
Alpha brain nootropics and things along
those lines.
The amount of food that you would have
to eat to get the same nutrients that
you would get from four Alpha brain
pills.
It's pretty fucking substantial.
You'd have to eat like bowls of Moss and
you gotta keep that shit fresh and you
wouldn't be able to take it on a plane.
There's a lot of issues with it.
Um,
also I think that when we isolate and
locate various components of food that
are beneficial for people like that is a
scientific thing.
Like there's this idea of anti-science
in connection to nutrients and vitamins
and nothing could be crazier.
The,
the issue is that some of them are being
sold without this science and that some
of them are just bullshit and we add on
it are very committed to making sure
anything we sell has some sort of
benefit.
That's absolutely provable.
If you go to Alpha brain and read the
research page,
we've conducted our own studies.
We conducted our,
we're in the middle of the second one
right now.
We conducted one a,
a double blind placebo controlled study
that showed benefit and memory,
showed a couple statistically measurable
numbers and you could see those.
We have it all listed and we also have
all the data that is currently
available.
All the studies that have been on been
done on the individual ingredients,
which is very important to point out
before we sell anything.
Before we do it,
we make sure that there's data on the
individual ingredients first.
The idea behind things like Alpha brain
are that you can combine various
nutrients and use them in a synergistic
fashion,
but sound smart when I say that,
but I'm actually really dumb,
so don't listen to me.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and read all
that shit.
On top of that,
we sell the very best strength and
conditioning equipment that you could
buy.
I like kettlebells.
I'm a huge fan of them because I believe
that you,
when you're swinging things and using
momentum and using your whole body as
one unit,
it mimics actions that you would have in
the real world.
Like even just like moving furniture or
something like that.
Like there's Kettlebell exercises that
would make you better at picking up shit
and moving around your houses,
practicals that kettlebell swings.
Um,
when you're doing pass throughs in
between your legs,
like you're doing figure eights in
between your legs with kettlebells when
you're doing cleans and presses and
cleans and jerks.
All those different exercises to
strengthen your whole body as an
individual unit.
And when it comes to this,
the term human optimization,
I mean that it embodies it in my
opinion,
that's what I'm interested in it.
I think the human body should be like a
race car and I think that if you have a
race car and for whatever reason you
don't want to put race fuel in it,
and for whatever reason you don't want
to give it a 500 horsepower engine and
for whatever reason you want to give it
a big fat tires that grip the road.
Guess what?
Fuck face your race car is going to
suck.
It's going to suck.
It's just not gonna work as well as a
race car that is designed and
constructed by a guy who took his body
or a Gal who took their body and did the
best thing they could do for it.
Drank a lot of water.
Eight fresh leafy green vegetables takes
in a lot of high quality protein and
exercise.
Make that mother fucker work.
You got to exercise.
It's one of the most critical parts of
life because if your body doesn't think
that it has to do anything,
guess what?
It just starts to go soft and get
useless.
If your body doesn't think that it has
to work,
he goes,
well,
we don't have to use any resources.
Uh,
staying healthy and fit.
Let's just fucking turn into a ball
mush.
Don't let that shit happen to you
people.
All right,
go to [inaudible] dot com,
o n n I t,
and if you use the Codeword Rogan,
you will save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
All supplements have a 100 percent money
back guarantee.
First 30 pills for 90 days.
You don't even have to return the pills.
Just say,
hey man,
I took new mood.
I didn't feel any better.
Well,
you're a fucking freak.
Here's your money back.
Okay?
And if you're mad at us,
you are selling snake oil.
Go read the research behind it.
There's a reason why we sell it.
And the reason is we are trying to give
people an edge and edge in life and edge
that I,
myself personally enjoy.
God,
that sounds Douchey,
but it is true.
I think you get an edge in how I,
I will,
I will say it in reference to my own
self because the only reference I really
have,
I don't know how other people feel,
but my own self when I'm eating healthy,
I exercise regularly and I take
supplements.
I feel better on a.com
o n n I t use the Codeword Rogan save 10
percent off any and all supplements
again tonight.
Uh,
is there any tickets left?
yeah.
There's ice house comedy dot Com and
it's a Sarah Tiana Joe Rogan a Tony
Hinchcliffe,
Greg Fitzsimmons.
So powerful show.
Uh,
and it's in the little room at the Ice
House,
which is so much fun.
And by the way,
Joey Diaz and Mad Flavor,
I'm Aka mad flavor rather.
And Dom irrera will be at the ice house
in the big room at the same time.
So it's a fucking party.
The Ice House,
my friends.
All right.
Without any further ado,
Lewis from unbox therapy's here.
Let's fucking geek out.
Let's do it.
Experience podcast shows up
podcasts and he's got a bunch of shit
that if I saw on the shelf,
I'd be like,
Ooh,
yeah,
I,
I figured coming straight from Google io
that it would make a lot of sense to
bring some of this stuff inside would
have been ashamed to.
What exactly is Google io?
Uh,
it's their developers conference,
so it's focused on bringing together
people that are making apps,
sort of Google centric type of
applications,
but it's also turned a consumer facing
conference because a lot of people are
paying attention at that time.
I think they had a million concurrent
streamers of the actual event.
So a million,
a million worldwide.
So current,
concurrent,
she's,
it's incredible.
It sounded like too much to me,
but I'm not going to question google.
Well that's a good television show on
HBO,
right?
Isn't it?
I mean like if,
uh,
what does game?
I don't think they do.
I don't think.
I don't know if they do a concurrent.
I guess it would be.
I would imagine.
I mean,
a lot of his dvr this day and age,
that's what I was wondering else.
Everything's Dvr,
so it has to be an event where you sort
of feel like you need to capture your
catchy and live or else you're going to
miss something.
Whereas,
I mean,
you could watch the Google io conference
after,
but yeah,
a lot of people paying a lot of
attention to the things they were doing.
What do those Mac world conferences,
those are the big ones,
right?
What do those.
Not Anymore,
not anymore.
A WWDC.
Apple holds its own conferences now,
so Mac world was actually like an
independent body and they just used it
as a vehicle to introduce new products.
It was like a convention for Mac,
apple and apple related stuff and they
decided to opt out of all third party
conventions.
They're not at ces in any form.
Apples,
not apple.
They want to control the entire
experience.
And so many of them happened on their
campus and then some happened in
downtown San Francisco like Google Io.
That's a big point of debate and
dispute,
isn't it?
With apple?
Yeah.
The controlled environment.
Yeah,
definitely.
For sure.
Uh,
I mean there's,
there's good sides and bad sides to that
kind of approach.
Obviously controlling the entire
software and hardware experience means
that you're going to get a product that
generally is fairly polished,
but from an innovation standpoint it
means you're sort of cutting off your
limbs in a sense that you're not
bringing people into that development
circle that might have otherwise been
there because it is sort of a walled
garden effect.
Yeah.
Isn't that fascinating?
I always remember the back in the day
when the clones were legal,
it was,
oh,
right.
Apple clones be able to go and there
were stores that would construct you and
an apple computer like semi recently
macintosh's they were called not even
semi recently,
a long time ago.
Used to be actual retail distributors to
sell Mac products.
Way more powerful than apple was making.
It would sell them with five fucking
hard drives and souped up.
I built a couple other way back and then
apple just put the Kibosh on that.
Yeah,
I,
I can almost remember the name of the
big company.
It was like either cylon or something.
Yes,
I think it was siloed and there is some
kind of court case and they had to stay.
I don't think you want to go up against
apple in court.
Well,
back then apple was way weaker but still
formidable till scariest,
but they.
So they now are the one computer,
but the problem is if you look at it
from the product point of view,
right?
They make the best shit.
They just do.
They make the best.
They make the best desktops.
They make the shit that crashes the
least.
They make an operating system.
That's the most I would say they make
the best shit for the most people.
For the most people.
Yeah,
because I think that if you really want
to get in there and tinker,
if you're like a heavy duty power user,
a lot of this like you look at this Mac
book air or your Mac book pro,
there's so much of it that's embedded.
It requires the entire package top or
you want to go in there and put more ram
in it or something or a swap out a hard
drive.
It's not gonna happen.
You got to bring it somewhere and the
geniuses at the apple geniuses.
Tentious you look,
I love apple,
but how fucking dare you.
How do you feel about the apple store
experience in general?
I enjoy it.
Yeah.
You know,
for the most part,
I think it's um,
it's a very busy place when it comes to
selling computers.
Right?
Remember when windows tried to have a
windows store and they're still trying
coyote hunting.
They're fun coyotes.
I know nobody in those fucking things.
I took a picture of an empty one before
and tweeted it out and everybody got it.
They don't,
they're not.
They're not known for selling hardware.
Right,
right.
They were a software company.
You see a Microsoft sign on a,
in a mall.
It's like,
what?
What am I buying here?
As an ignorant person,
I'm ignorant to it.
As far as development development of a
product,
like a laptop,
I'm pretty ignorant.
I don't know too much other than the
things I've vaguely paid attention to
online.
What is stopping someone from making
like a super high end windows laptop
that looks like this,
that feels there are so many that look
and feel like this,
that are this high quality and they give
you the same experience?
No,
because you're running windows is
windows so much worse.
They have so much money.
Drop the ball out of the drought but
pretty bad after the windows experience
of 19 whatever.
Like they dropped the ball,
they dropped it and then they shit on it
and then they fell on it and then they
broke their hip.
I know,
I mean I don't want to speak for
everyone,
but I don't recall any experience with
windows where I cracked open a laptop
lid and felt that kind of experience
ever.
So even when x p was the thing or even
before that 95 or however far back you
want to go,
you didn't get that same pleasure.
You get out of booting up an apple
product and getting into the eos and
seeing the cohesion of the whole thing.
Windows,
even in the old days was sort of like a
necessary evil windows was the way to
get to the shit you actually liked
whether you wanted to download a game or
a web browser or whatever,
but on its own it was.
It's always been utilitarian.
It's always been ugly.
Yeah.
I always end with the dudes who ran nt
windows nt guys.
So it's a really new thing.
Oh,
right,
right.
He's running into.
Oh,
and there's a bunch of shit you couldn't
get like drivers for certain video
cards.
Like if you wanted to play games,
if you rent and ti,
it'd be real issues for people do that
now with Linux.
That's sort of the counterculture.
OSTP.
Yeah,
like off the grid.
Opensource savages.
Yeah.
Ibm actually originally that and now I
don't know who it.
It's just open source.
If it's in anyone's hands now I do think
apple is the best of making an operating
system slowly die,
like have a,
like a cancer instead of just
immediately like I'm going through an
experience right now where my Imac is
just dying.
It's the operating time.
I read it a scratch,
I put new memory in it and stuff like
that.
The operating systems,
just saying like this model,
you need to replace it soon.
This is the Brian redband conspiracy
theory,
conspiracy theory.
When it comes to operating systems
with iphones,
everyone knows you.
You have an iphone four and you get the
new operating system.
We've got all the new updates.
That's going to be way slower.
Even some programs might not work.
It's not always the case.
There is.
That does happen.
Like there are sometimes things that
happen within an eos that require more
hardware to be able to perform at the
same level of non Brian's worlds goddamn
conspiracy to trying to get people to
buy these new fucking things.
Well,
I mean if you want to get a Mac pro,
go for it.
Like there.
They're beautiful things,
but it seems like with this or with a
Samsung galaxy note three or whatever,
when new shit gets made new
possibilities,
you're going to need more processing
power.
You're going to get an apps require
more.
The new videos that they're taking,
the new photographs,
we take Bursa photographs.
God,
there's got to be some processing going
on.
Definitely going to need a faster ship
rig.
That's just the way it is.
There's no doubt that the.
Especially on the apple products,
but in general there's this.
There's this structure built in where
the expectation is to upgrade your
device every time that contract is up.
Right?
Well,
I think there's no option if you want
to.
If you're in the game,
if you're in this loving electronics
that everyone in this room's,
then we're all fucking dork and hammers
when it comes.
That's right.
New Electronics.
When you're in that game,
you have to keep up.
If you do not keep up,
if you try to run an iphone three on the
newest iphone software,
it's going to be clunky because the
iphone three didn't have near the
capabilities and these new applications.
Each new video that you can take the
photos,
you can take the new weird things.
You can measure your heartbeat with your
fucking,
with your camera lens,
with this watch.
You can do with your watch,
but you didn't do it with your iphone.
Can do it or an android phone can do it
just by holding your finger over the
camera lens and it measured.
Jamie showed it to me.
I thought it was written thing.
It would work.
I at work.
I don't believe it's a super active.
I know I did it with a regular heart
monitor.
Yeah,
I did it with a chest heart monitor and
I did it without at the same time.
It's dead on.
Wow.
I have a new watch though.
That does it on your wrist.
You don't have to.
You don't have to wear a chest strap
anymore.
He's got the newest watch that we're in
now.
I can see it on the bottom.
There is.
That's the heart monitor on the bottom
was watching.
Oh,
that's so pretty.
so pretty.
How'd you make it green?
It was green for a second.
Oh,
it might've been.
That might've gone into sleep mode or
something.
What's the model that watch?
So that's the uh,
gear live they're
calling it,
which is kind of bizarre.
They tried to get me into this at the
verizon store.
I told him to go fuck themselves.
Yeah,
they probably try to get you into the
old version of it because this isn't
even on the market yet.
Are you devil you're one of those guys?
Yeah.
We'll look at that color.
I made it to go green.
So yeah,
uh,
the difference here between the previous
Samsung watches and this one is this is
the first to be running the open
platform that,
that Google has created.
So not a modified version of software.
It's running something called android
wear.
And what Google is hoping to do to do on
your wrist is essentially replicate what
they've done on the phone.
And if you look into it,
this is the risk thing.
That thing in there is the monitor.
That's right.
So it's optical.
It's actually going to look under the
surface of your skin and it has like a
class on the back that locks into place.
It's crazy.
And so the,
the beauty of this going this direction
with it is if you can build a platform
instead of a one off device,
then uh,
the,
the likelihood that a developer will
jump into it and build something really
cool that you never foresaw happening is
that much higher because of the mass
market effect.
If everyone's running the same software
on their wrist,
it's better for everyone.
And uh,
so,
so there's this kind of love hate
relationship between Samsung and Google
over this because for the longest time
Samsung has been trying to diminish its
a reliance on Google as a,
as a whole for their brand.
It's so essential for them to sell
products.
And so they've been moving into some
different operating systems now that are
not very good.
But independent of Google.
Yeah.
This is awesome,
man.
Yeah.
So I can,
I can tell you some of what he does.
I mean,
it,
it's not really that much new
comparative to the old smartwatches.
Essentially you're gonna get your
notifications here.
It has a microphone on it so that,
uh,
you can input a voice commands,
et cetera.
So if you,
for example,
want to text somebody back,
you can catch the notification here,
respond to the text right on your wrist
and leave your phone in your pocket.
A,
they were saying on stage that they
believe 70 percent of our interaction
with our device could be curbed by
having one of these on your wrists.
So essentially most of the day your
phone could remain in your pocket.
But I was talking earlier with Brian
about how really the goal here,
the end game is preemptive computing.
So,
uh,
the idea that this thing will know what
you want to do before you know that you
want to do it.
Uh,
and that's what Google now has been
pushing,
has been pushing in that direction.
So your flight lands and it can,
it can estimate how long it's going to
take you to get home.
Or the proximity sensor says that you're
in the airport,
so it looks at your travel itinerary and
brings up your boarding pass right on
your wrist.
So those kinds of things are what make
wearing something on,
on your exterior more interesting where
a,
a buzzing in your pocket is maybe not as
effective as the information you can get
here.
Like so travel distance and things along
those lines,
things that updates those updates that
you get on
your phone,
but your warnings.
So things like that.
But again,
I don't know that we can necessarily
imagined all the potential uses for
preemptive computing.
I mean essentially much like the nest
Thermostat,
I don't know if you've heard of that
before.
It's a really fancy thermostats you put
in your house and it's alert.
It's a learning thermostat and they just
took over the marketplace.
They recently got acquired by Google,
by the way.
Uh,
and one of their designers was one of
the original guys who worked on Ipod.
So really there's a,
there's a cool story there.
But,
uh,
anyways,
they acquired nest.
Nest product is a learning thermostat
that never needs to be programmed.
The programming is just you using it.
So you come,
it's Wifi connected,
you come home and you adjust it and you
don't realize there's patterns in your
behavior that at 3:00
you always like it to be a certain
temperature and at six it's different
and eventually it will dry out in
algorithm to deal with your behavior,
at which point you no longer need to
ever worry about it or touch it.
The goal of the product is to require
less and less interaction from you.
The more you use it.
What's weird about nest is that they
also have these new products where they
just,
they're now taking over washer and
dryers.
They're getting to the point where it is
going to be like that old flintstones
where they control their,
the central computer of your house.
And there's like,
hello computer,
what are you doing here?
But what they are.
And they also have these uh,
uh,
smoke detectors that also do carbon,
carbon monoxide and stuff like that.
So they could even turn off and be like,
oh,
this,
turn on the oven,
gas this guy and kill him.
So Google is going to be able to murder
us in her house and warn you if
someone's breaking into your house
trying to murder,
you know,
they,
they just acquired drop camp,
which is a jack was preaching about
forever because the drop cam is one of
the greatest,
I think inventions in a long time.
It's these little cameras that film
amazing hd,
uh,
and that you could put all over your
house that connect to your Wifi and then
you get a text like,
oh,
somebody is walking through my house.
You're sitting there watching full hd.
It's recording in the cloud for you.
Recording our stuff.
Right.
And it could also learn certain things,
like,
just watch this part of the house,
you know,
if it's me walking around because it's
doing detections of what kind of object
motions it is.
Do you shut all that off cover with tee
shirts when he fucked you put socks over
them when I remember.
And then of course that he needs that.
You need to have that in the cloud.
No,
no,
I need that.
No,
I need that in the clouds.
I can get hacked.
But I also need,
how about as proof,
whatever,
like that video we were talking about
that,
that the,
that a guy that was doing the drone over
the beach and that woman attacked,
attacked him,
and he had recorded.
If it wasn't for that,
his little recording there,
what would have happened?
She said that he attacked her,
right?
Yeah.
There was beating the shit out of 'em.
But what if you meet a girl at a bar,
you're both drunk and you go back to
your living room.
Like that comedian,
that judge.
I just happened to a comic I recently
and Denver and uh,
and he got in a whole bunch of trouble.
How do you feel about that world though?
Everything being recorded.
That's the question I was going to ask.
It's going to be great once something
bad happens,
when it's.
Nothing's bad to happen.
I
don't really care.
You know?
I'm sort of.
Except if you do something fucked up and
someone gets a hold of it.
Yeah,
just don't do anything fucked up.
It's great.
It's like that Lego movie.
Everything is awesome.
Is it really?
I don't know if it's really that simple
though because in,
I mean you've seen,
you've seen before,
like the effect of say for example,
editing on the end product on a show or
something like that.
You can totally change context,
change narrative.
Somebody having footage of you doing any
kind of behavior could potentially be
used to harm you,
but we all know if you have a photoshop
that there's wastage detective,
it's photoshop.
If there's an editor,
there's.
There's so much smart little algorithms
that you can tell that there's one grain
that's not supposed to be there in a
film as far as like actually altering
the image itself,
but not the context of the image itself.
You know,
you could,
you could have someone doing something
that's actually not fucked up and you
knew the whole story,
but yeah,
that's yeah,
that it's an issue.
It's certainly an issue and it's
certainly an issue because there's
people that have that power over others.
You know?
That's what the real issue with the NSA
is like,
wait a minute,
you're monitoring every single person in
the country that use,
assuming we're all criminals,
because if not,
then do you pick a target like that you
know,
is innocent.
Is it okay for you to monitor them?
No,
it's not right.
We all agree.
So the only reason why it's okay as
you're looking at us all as potential
criminals,
that's a real issue.
That's for sure.
Definitely just that philosophy of
government,
that philosophy of ruling over people
because it's omnipotent.
For sure.
On my way over this just reminded me of
something or before I left the hotel,
I saw on the TV about that guy whose kid
died in the backseat of his car.
I don't know if you've heard about this
in Georgia.
His,
uh,
so he leave the kid in the back left.
How old was the kid?
The kid was toddler,
left him in the backseat,
overheated and died.
And today I guess they find out the dude
was googling hot car,
death,
backseat death prior to the event.
Just to see how long did it on purpose.
That's the thought.
Oh No,
he was saying how long he could leave
his kid in there while he runs in and
gets a fine,
but that's pretty.
That's pretty fucked up on its own,
man.
Either one is fucked up.
He tried to kill this kid.
He killed his kid pc.
It's the problem is stories like that
resonate so close to home that you're
like,
fuck it.
Give them all the power they need.
You can't.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Well that's how I feel sometimes telling
him,
pull this up,
dude.
I don't want to see that guy's.
Yeah.
No,
you don't like.
Sometimes I feel like that when it comes
to like location services,
do you want google to know where you
are?
Right.
I got to think about where am I?
What am I doing?
I showed them on yesterday's podcast how
everyone's iphones has on default.
Just all the locations that they sit at.
Yep.
That's right.
Very strange that that's it is.
And you and you,
you really start to wonder about all of
this power we give to these devices over
us,
uh,
to these companies that,
that we have this inherent trust.
We're at a point now where we rely on
these things to a degree that doesn't
really allow for an opt out.
You know,
I'm not for me,
obviously now for this podcast,
you know,
not,
not for all kinds of exercise.
And if we knew that the police and the
dea and the whatever organization that
might be investigating you was
infallible and super ethical.
There was no corruption.
There was no issues whatsoever with the
lying in order to close cases to go look
better.
Right?
But we know that's true.
We know that's true.
We know there's been a lot of
prosecutors that have willingly put
people in jail because they didn't want
to admit they were wrong.
They got the wrong person.
One of those stories always messed me up
when this guy gets let out of jail 25
years later on DNA.
It seems like the only truth is the
scientific truth.
You know,
it seems there's no other truth once
it's in human being's hands,
it's like Google with these self driving
cars like they can.
They can eliminate so much.
Yeah.
Almost like 90 percent are human error,
right?
Look,
look at airplanes,
how their safety records are insane and
the majority of that pro,
we'll put a plane in the sky and let it
fly itself,
but we won't let a car on the road do so
yet.
The number one way that you will die
between the ages of four and 34 is in a
vehicle.
Well,
we're letting it happen.
When you say we're not going to let it
happen,
like they're letting google cars
happened.
They're driving them right now for.
Well they're out there but they're not
publicly available.
There will be some.
You can't.
I mean the oil and gas companies that
dealerships liquidated to Tesla in New
Jersey there.
I don't think there'll be able to do
that.
Not long term,
not long term,
but they can put,
you know,
sorta like the marijuana thing in
Colorado.
Like it's.
It ebbs and flows,
right?
Yeah.
It goes a little bit this way and I was
back that way.
I think it'd be so transparent though.
It'd be the real issue,
like why would you try to avoid
something that is easy,
convenient and unbelievably safe.
It'll just.
There'll be somebody with some kind of
economic.
I think personal freedom issues are
going to still apply.
Like I liked to be able to drive our.
Yeah,
that's true.
Could you imagine a point at which that
becomes illegal?
I mean,
is that what happened?
Definitely.
I mean,
or you could have to take your car to a
fucking race track.
You imagine if the only way you could
drive your Subaru was taking on a
racetrack.
Well,
but if you haven't,
if you haven't relic.
I always,
I sometimes feel like on the regular
roads if you have a really nice car,
it's kind of like,
you know,
putting a muzzle on the dog,
you really to to get the most out of it.
A race track would be good anyways.
That is definitely true to get the most
out of it,
but you can get something.
Yeah.
No,
definitely.
Definitely.
You can still get something you get a
lot out of it depends on where it rode.
Take like a angel's crest forest,
right?
The Angeles Crest highway.
You're,
you've been up there,
you know,
like out near where that gun ranges to
all these crazy winding.
Beautiful.
So fun to drive.
There is a way.
It's just that unfortunately 98 percent
of the way people drive sucks.
Like you're sitting in gridlock.
First of all,
your phone should not receive or send
tax once it's in the phone.
Once it's in the car should be a thing
where the,
the,
the car recognizes
actually a bluetooth that your phone is
a good segue.
No tax.
Fuck.
That's a good segue because one of the
announcements actually at Google io was
googling the car,
which,
uh,
again,
talks to all these different devices and
is essentially going to overhaul your
car dash unit.
Which by the way,
they all suck.
They're all terrible.
Everyone's experienced the shitty
capacitive screens in the slow input and
pretty much everyone agrees,
just slapping your phone in the center
of the dash that's going to give you a
better experience than the three or
$4,000
a unit that the car company installed a
apparently.
Part of what holds them back is that
they have to have approval so far in
advance,
three years or four years or something
to get to get approved to go into a
motor vehicle that they can't.
You know,
that they're so far behind by the time
you're actually driving it,
that you've got a crappy experience.
But the goal here for,
for Google is that your phone is
actually the brain because this is
modular,
this changes.
You upgrade this all the time.
Your car on the other hand,
not so much.
So if this is the brain doing all the
processing and just outputting video to
a monitor,
that also happens to be touch screen.
You don't necessarily have to worry
about that.
So much new points of interest on Nav,
for example.
Uh,
they don't happen on these,
these locked off circumstances.
Whether you have a,
you know,
a vw or a Ford or whatever,
each one of those experiences relies on
those companies to go input those new
pos.
So a new restaurant opens,
it's not going to be there.
Whereas in the case of this,
it's always going to be current
information.
So the phone will sort of the car rather
we're sort of act as an app sort of.
I would honestly think of it as more of
an as an output method.
So like basically imagine when you plug
this in,
when you plug this phone into a TV,
you would see this,
let's say you say see this image up on
the screen there.
So let's imagine the same thing but on
your car dash right?
Why not?
Why,
why we're all doing this anyway.
So that's say phone would be an APP,
but I'm in your car would be an APP.
Yeah.
Essentially your car where you'd plug
into your phone.
I mean that's ever seen.
Those dudes who run those really large
lenses,
they take photographs,
they plugged it in and there's
apparently there's software that allows
you to use these lenses with certain
cell phones.
Oh really?
You haven't seen that?
Yeah.
They make large lenses.
Jamie,
you know about all that shit.
Right.
The like a physical adapter.
Yeah.
They put like your lap and I've seen
some of them have applications that go
along.
Definitely sort of the car is sort of
acting like that.
Yeah,
an extension and there's some sort of an
application that allow your car to
interface with your phone.
The only thing is we would be.
You wouldn't have to do any work.
Essentially it would be baked into your
phone and if you never used it you'd
never need to worry about it,
but you would have to have a specific
operating system though because like say
if you have a Subaru and Subaru only
handles android,
but.
Exactly,
exactly.
So they announced like 50 auto
manufacturers that are on board.
That makes sense.
That's a huge pain that dick though,
when it comes to switching phones,
like I like going back and this and this
is something that I wanted to talk about
how now with more and more devices,
it's becoming super important to pick
your team.
Oh No,
you're separating people.
It's.
I like both.
I really do.
I love my note.
I love the screen.
The screen is incredible.
I love the online experience,
but you know what I got recently,
man,
I got to fucking IPAD air.
The big one with a horizon connection is
that I got this connection happen.
Yep.
Yeah.
My web browsing with a laptop or you
know,
I mean my website is done with a phone
or basically over.
Do you know what's great about this I
suggest is when you're on the road,
I had t and t as my wife or as my cell
phone,
but a lot of places [inaudible] and t
sucks or vice versa and you could just
make a hotspot using this so you're
always having the best time.
Could have a boy.
Well,
here's,
here's an interesting thing there in
that picking a,
picking a platform,
maybe it won't be such an issue in the
future anyways because I,
I sort of view as much as I like apple.
I mean I've got products here,
I use the iphone is in my pocket daily.
You've got this laptop here,
they have no track zero traction in
emerging markets at all.
It's not even of interest to them.
They sell here and only here,
I don't know about you,
but I'm American.
I don't really give a fuck about some
mud hut yet except that those people in
those mud huts are making killer apps
now.
Oh dammit.
And if their first device that they get
their hands on happens to be an android
device that matters,
right?
Yeah.
This is a global circumstance.
I,
I've been saying for awhile that it's
almost like apple can't win because even
though they have really high level stuff
and you start looking at like the moto m
eight,
you go,
Ooh,
that's pretty God damn close to an
iphone.
Right?
If it just had a better camera,
the camera's kind of whack.
Oh.
Oh,
I heard you guys talk about this before
this.
I wanted to talk about this
specifically.
Cell or cell phone cameras.
Okay.
Everybody in the tech world knows that
distinct takes the best instagram
photos.
Right.
Okay.
I said that specifically because it's
the number one way or the way that we
share photos and ultimately how you
share it is the biggest part of it.
Who cares if it looks great on your
phone when when other people have to
have to look at it.
If it doesn't.
So other phones came out and you guys
talked to him.
There was one from note instagram.
You saying this go.
I keep talking.
All right,
so other devices came out.
It was a Gnocchi devices,
a 41 megapixel phone.
I'm a windows phone 40.
What?
40 one megapixel.
But you see that device is not focused
on the output method.
It's just like let's just make these
crazy images that are huge.
Well,
how the hell do I get that thing on
instagram for the longest time windows
phone didn't even have instagram,
but here's the problem.
Okay.
Instagram is a piece of software and in
order for it to work smoothly,
it has to compress your photos.
Okay,
so the thing you're taking on your phone
just in the camera app is not the same
thing that other people end up seeing on
the other side of instagram.
Right.
You know what I mean,
and that compression algorithm is very
sophisticated.
It has to go in there and figure out
what can I remove and what do I need to
leave in time to make a beautiful
picture.
Right now,
if you're building the Ios side of
Instagram,
of that APP,
it's very easy to build because what are
your parameters?
It's the same camera every time,
right?
Android,
Holy Shit.
How many android phones are on the
market?
A lot of fucking android phones.
So now how many parameters as a
developer do you need to deal with?
Because all those phones have different
attributes.
So the way they take a picture is
different.
So going in and trying to figure out
what to remove in terms of bits and
bytes to still have a good picture on
the other side is very difficult to do.
So it's not necessarily a technical
limitation on the side of the device.
The galaxy s five for example,
has a great camera,
a great camera until you try to upload
to instagram.
Well,
I'm talking,
I'm talking
talking about taking photos on my camera
on both and trying to take the best
photos,
right?
No,
no,
that's.
That exists.
This is a great camera.
Don't get me wrong.
It has a big aperture.
Is still like in terms of mass market,
you can argue this against the Nokia one
just because that's how it hangs off the
back.
It's a giant thing,
but what I'm saying is the bigger
problem,
I believe the bigger problem is the
instagram problem.
People,
people,
people hit me up on twitter all the
time,
like my photos look great.
Then I uploaded it,
looked like mud.
They looked like shit.
You know,
once I get them up there.
So this,
this,
this goes deep tech guys will carry
around two devices for that specific
reason.
I will take pictures on,
even if I took a picture on here,
but if I uploaded it on here it would be
different.
That's good.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I mean when I upload my photos from both
of my devices that note three and my
iphone five s all my fucking phone's all
my gal or notes photos are shit compared
to this camera.
They're not as good.
And if you have a program like instagram
that is taking random,
there's a lot of times I use instagram
but just like photos I find on the
Internet,
like screenshots,
that's another good example.
And those programs should be able to be
like,
okay,
we're going to make everything a
screenshot that's uploaded through this,
you know,
algorithm like meaning.
Like if you have a photo that's taken on
one camera,
you have a screenshot,
you have a camera that you uploaded,
whatever.
All those photos should be able to go
through one single program and thing
like we're all going to transfer this
into what a screenshot is of that phone
or whatever.
Meaning it shouldn't be like who cares
if it what different photos that is.
It's the programming that should be able
to interpret it and no doubt about it,
but it's just.
If you say you're the developer on
Instagram,
first of all,
instagram is not really making much
money right now anyways,
but if you're good,
could they be.
That's a question.
I mean people pay for Instagram,
facebook,
facial recognition so that they can own
all your apps.
One APP,
download it.
You downloaded for free or do you pay
for it?
No,
it's a free app,
but at the u you will eventually start
to see promoted instagram posts from
brands in your feed.
No choice.
Twitter's doing.
Do they own what I was doing?
They gross me out when they do read
them.
Promoting your friend is following x
brand's instagram.
Own your photos.
Are they allowed to use whatever?
Oh,
they recently they updated their tos
because they said that and then people
freaked out and then they monitored it
and I'm not,
I'm not sure what the current state of
their terms of services,
but uh,
honestly instagram is probably my
favorite social network outside of
youtube because it's streamlined.
It's images,
it's fast,
it's not too much.
Facebook is a disaster,
you know,
and I mean,
I'm pretty sure that's why they
purchased them.
For example,
if I put a picture on Instagram from an
interactivity stamp,
this is how,
you know,
software is working when people want to
use it.
If I put a picture on Instagram,
I think the comment stream is happening
faster than anywhere else,
even though I don't have the same number
of followers.
There were a lot of douchebags on
instagram though.
Oh,
maybe more than on twitter.
Oh yeah.
Lauren,
can we do a Douche bag?
Is Definition when you say douchebag
there,
I'm curious as to the what specifically?
Just dumb assholes.
Oh,
okay.
Dot.
Oh yeah.
Lots of the assholes.
Like you ever go to Kim Kardashians
instagram page,
none of them a little weasel.
Go there and just read some of the
fucking comments about children.
Anything.
Anything that's a fucking.
Hey,
I'm sure it's.
I'm sure it's there.
Diluted Youtube.
It's because it's you're,
you're,
you're commenting on a photo or a video
instead of a twitter where you're just
talking about words.
I honestly think anything worth anything
should be comments,
deleted,
comics disabled,
because the problem is they very rarely,
it's,
it's rare that you.
It generates a really fascinating
conversation in the comments.
It's super common.
That is just shitheads.
It depends on the subject matter.
In my case,
sometimes I do get relevant discussion
in the comments,
a tech discussion,
like they're pretty respectful,
but you do get this weird fanboys and
stuff that gets militant.
Surprisingly.
It's like a more way.
I don't know.
I have this theory like,
you know when you go to a coffee shop
and you look around you at starbucks,
everyone has their phones on the table.
You notice that like it's in a public
space.
It's like,
it's like representative of you in some
way and I have this feeling that this is
for a lot of people,
this is a major investment,
you know,
outside of their car or whatever.
It's really close to you.
It's in your pocket all the time.
And so I think people are really
concerned with making the wrong
decision,
you know,
they're really concerned that their
thing is not the best.
And so in my case,
what will happen is I'll put up a video
within,
you know,
they haven't even had time to finish
watching it and apple socs or android
sucks or whatever.
And really it's fear.
It's fear that you made the wrong
decision and so,
well,
like many places in life,
you get angry when you're afraid.
And so,
God forbid a new product comes out that
obsoletes yours and you don't have the
money to replace it.
So you,
you,
you take this position of defending the
other thing because that's easier than
justifying the cost of the new one.
So,
uh,
I've,
I've actually,
uh,
there were a couple of really cool
articles on Fanboy ism that I was
interviewed for and you know,
we went,
we went deep into how,
you know,
how people sort of figure that out.
But uh,
there's definitely this undercurrent
below the tech space,
the consumer product space where these
are becoming more and more like fashion
symbols,
like,
like a,
you know,
rep,
representative of your personality maybe
more so than this then as a tool,
you know,
less,
less of a hammer and more like a,
a piece of jewelry,
like a watch or something.
Isn't it also that people just love
being on teams,
whether it's team.
Oh,
Publican team shelly most,
most definitely.
And I've done some rants on this in the
past.
Like I,
I feel the need to tell people like I'm
a fan of technology when I was coming up
as a kid,
like if anybody brought me any of this
stuff I would,
I would be super excited of course.
And I'm cool with saying that,
you know,
but uh,
but yeah,
there is,
there is definitely a team aspect where
people,
they want to belong to something I say
belong to team technology if that's what
you're into because the truth is these
devices and these platforms push one
another that the positive things that
happened in android push ios to be
better in the positive things that
happened in Ios push android to be
better.
And the same thing goes for laptops,
desktops really anywhere.
There's innovation.
Having a little bit of competition is a
positive thing.
Yeah,
unquestionably.
And I think that it's important that
there's all this competition out there
and it's important that there's debate,
but people just have to be good is just
assholes.
So solar,
that's true as well.
Really what it is,
they're out there.
People just getting off slobber mouth.
Well if there their various platforms
need to do right,
getting angry is probably the easiest
thing to do.
You know,
like I mean in terms of emotions,
anger is,
is a reaction that people that don't
have the ability to process something,
they choose anger.
It's the easiest one.
So,
but yeah,
any kind of like those,
those are not the dominating comments.
I not definitely not on my stuff.
The dominating ones are more along the
lines of uh,
you know,
like I said,
technology in general,
being happy about innovation.
You post a new unboxing video of one of
these things and everybody's cool with
it and everybody's interested and that's
part of the reason why people watch my
videos is because they sort of want to
see.
They want to see the whole movement of
the place in general.
Like I could,
it could have been an apple channel.
A lot of people do that,
like they'll have like an,
an ios related channel,
whether they'll do app reviews
specifically for a platform or
something.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
I don't want to give them a bad rap
completely.
They're not all Douche bag.
No,
no,
there's not.
Yeah.
I mean it's a small,
loud minority really.
I mean,
but that loud minority can ruin.
That's a problem.
I mean a youtube implemented this idea
where you have your real name,
that's a great idea.
You know,
I love that idea.
They show a fucking picture of you two
and a picture of you when you wake up in
the morning.
What the fuck.
So and so cocky now about Kim Kardashian
run little cute.
So yeah,
I mean that's one way to remove
anonymity on the web,
but a lot of people don't necessarily
like,
like for example,
on Reddit.
I mean,
could there ever be your real identity
on reddit?
That's interesting.
You know,
there's,
there's benefits,
there's pros and cons.
There's benefits to anonymity because a
lot of times you'll get truth that
someone might shield from you because of
the social stigma,
you know,
just social cues and interactions.
They might just back off of it and go
out.
I wasn't honest with them.
If you go to see someone in a movie,
you know,
like when you think man,
like Oh fucking piece of shit to say
that you go home,
it's pretty fucking good man.
If you were a random guy that there's so
many things wrong with this movie,
they should burn it on the Marae for
sure.
Say something like that.
And you would really mean that.
So I don't know.
Do you think that things are better for
people having that ability or would they
be better in the alternative space where
you.
Because you know anyways,
right when somebody really isn't into
something they don't really need to say
it.
Do they know?
You know,
you can feel it,
but I think that interaction in general,
I think first of all,
I think this stage that we're in this
stage of commenting and being able to
interact with people online,
just like you put up a video,
they could just shit all over your face.
You know the face guys doing something.
Anything.
Just decide that this is a new ability
that's never existed.
A decade ago,
two decades ago,
there was nothing remotely similar to
this.
Not that we don't really know how to
deal with it and there's so many people
that just get away with doing things on
it.
They would never do in real life share
just because they really shouldn't have
that ability.
It's not a natural ability.
The natural ability to communicate with
each other is it's an ebb and flow
interact.
It's not send a missile and sit back and
wait to explode.
Well,
that's the thing.
I mean,
not that you have the art form of
trolling,
like that's a whole thing and it is an
art form when done.
Well,
I mean it's sometimes there's this new
website that I just started following or
new twitter feed that I just started
following.
It's a total troll.
It's kind of a parody account.
Troll,
but it,
it turns into a troll.
I shot almost not say the name.
Anybody.
Yeah.
Well fuck it.
It's,
it's all about salon.com
and it's salon like their,
their twitter handle.
I think his salon.com,
like there's salon.
That is one.
Twitter handle their salon.com.
Hello?
Say I'll find out who it is on salon is
the official verified one.
Exactly,
exactly.
It's called Salon yet.
Salon.com
and it's hilarious.
It's.
It's really funny.
The unfortunate part of that is them
using that name.
Maybe a problem in the long run.
You're the one that you're want to
announce that.
Listen,
they need more people.
It's.
It's really funny.
There was a,
there was one about a kid,
a misogynist superheroes,
why?
Men's rights activists are wearing capes
and they're just trolling.
It's really funny,
man.
Yeah.
If it's sophisticated and well thought
out,
it's acceptable.
In my opinion,
Gary,
the six most popular video games that
allow you to kill female players online.
Uh,
the last antisemitic slur.
We need to stop using the j word
already.
Oh,
they're just trolling.
This is good.
That's gold.
I like this kind of trolling because if
you go to the fucking comments,
God,
there's a lot of people that do not
think this is trolling.
Really?
Isn't this the kind of trolling you
eight.
Awesome.
Well,
no,
because this is obvious,
but mom errands or gay for 10 year olds
vile rant to proves what a homophobic
patriarchy we live in.
I think it.
I think there's a place for it.
This place.
Come on,
man.
Anybody fucking reading that?
If it's look,
you don't deserve to be able to come and
it should be your,
your test.
If you really believe this,
you either not paying attention like
you're half awake.
How do you feel about that?
How do you feel about this?
What if,
what if there was some like reputation
attached to your name,
like because that's essentially what's
happening on Youtube,
right?
Right.
If you log onto a video and it happens
to be somebody in your google plus
circles,
for example,
they'll rise to the top of the.
Well,
that's why you shouldn't use google plus
because that's retarded.
You don't have a choice for commenting.
Now,
10 signs your cat might be racist.
Look,
you know,
there's.
There's a bunch of different ways to
look at it.
I don't think there's any,
there's any absolute,
but I think ultimately the real issue is
that we're just not used to this kind of
freedom,
this freedom of communication and
freedom of interaction,
freedom of reaching people,
feeding them.
You mean there's websites dedicated to
just like anything.
Like you could reach people,
you can contact people,
you could comment on people,
you could,
you could start your own website and
boom,
people comment on you.
Me,
this kind of interaction.
It's just,
it's completely.
It's an adolescent thing,
so when you have cases like that guy
that got fired because they outed him on
Reddit,
he used to do a lot of creepy shit on
reddit.
I remember that guy in Texas,
I believe he lived.
Yeah,
his name was something acres or
something.
Um,
and it was a really interesting debate
because obviously the guy was really
creepy online,
but to him it was like a role that he
was playing to him.
He got enjoyment out of this trolling
and posting pictures of dead people and
whatever the fuck he was doing.
His big one was creep shots,
right?
I think so,
like an up the skirt type picture,
which surprisingly,
for a long time if you searched for
reddit it was the top hit was like slash
creeps shots.
So I want to know who's searching reddit
for creep shots.
No,
they.
But here's the thing.
They banked a lot of dough on that guys
work,
right?
Oh,
read it did.
Of course,
if they're,
if they're accumulating traffic through
Google searches right to that particular
thread,
ultimately they earn money through
advertising revenue.
Like anyone else keeping people.
They're going to write,
but they're an open forum.
Completely Open Forum.
Not Completely.
Not completely because of moderated.
Is that what you mean?
So you're saying that by them
tolerating.
If so,
if it could be proved to the stollery
though he got,
he got a,
a red or a trophy,
a statute for being one of the best
moderators.
Uh,
and he did a lot of ups shots.
Yeah.
Creep shots was I think maybe the most
famous thread or a subreddit.
Sorry.
Oh No.
He ran a subreddit called creep shots
shots.
And there was another one.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
So reddit knew about the subreddit?
Yeah.
Oh,
that shit's sexy.
I don't care what you guys all.
Kilts.
All Scottish.
Still a,
you know,
like the idea,
the under age ones though.
He was also on.
So I'm under 18 only and I think,
I believe the goal was to attempt to
harvest pictures from girls,
facebook accounts.
So you would pretend to be,
you'd have like one of their friend's
profile pictures.
You'd beat somebody at their school or I
don't fake it,
get access and then pulled.
Pulled down the facebook photos and
upload them to the girls.
Had no idea they were showing up on this
subreddit until they found out at school
the next day.
Damn,
that is so fucked up.
And that was a grown man doing that to a
little girl.
And guess what the moderator's job was
to remove pictures of girls that look
too old.
Oh my God.
So what do you think about that?
What's your thoughts about that?
I,
I have a love hate relationship with
reddit.
Like this idea that,
that it's an open forum is one that
everybody believes,
but the vast majority of reddit users or
consumers and producers right there just
user to consume content.
You would never know if you're actually
seeing an open forum or not.
You're not managing it in any way.
So,
uh,
they're like super against self
promotion.
Right?
And this is how I've bumped into them a
number of times because I'll tweet out
if somebody's talking about me on
Reddit,
I'll tweet the link right on numerous
occasions tweeting that link brought the
whole post down.
Wow.
I just stayed in my sobriety.
I don't go out of Reddit March.
I think it's good for certain things
like,
like I use it for episode discussions,
a podcast,
the subreddit and Joe suburbs.
Still human beings.
There's obviously cool people.
They're like,
that's not up for discussion,
but these veiled moderators in the
background Canis essentially shape your
experience.
There
is also been issues with censorship.
Alexis Ohanian,
when he was on the podcast,
talked about issues of things being
censored,
a technology forums.
Oh,
definitely.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Certain certain keywords.
Yeah.
Certain keywords would knock the post
down immediately.
You couldn't type in those keywords.
Bull or whatever.
I strange list of keyword.
Someone did a little investigation on
it.
They did a little study.
I wonder if that's still the case.
I haven't attempted it.
We actually found this out.
I believe it was after Alexis was here,
so we didn't get a chance to ask him.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
if they're making money off of the fact
that their forum gets a tremendous
amount of traffic and you have a
subreddit that you're aware of,
someone must be aware of that,
correct?
Oh,
definitely.
It's not there anymore,
but how crazy is that?
The you're censoring things like the
word apple or Samsung or whatever,
whatever the technology words are,
you're censoring that,
but you're not censoring obscured shots
of 18 year old.
Here's the thing on fishing,
an 18 year old girls don't buy ads,
right?
It's the free promotion.
They don't want.
They don't want people come.
They don't want people hacking their
system in a way finding a way to get
exposure through their platform without
paying for it.
Right?
So,
you know,
twitter,
facebook,
doing the same thing.
Now if facebook promoted posts,
I don't know how active you guys are on
facebook,
but uh,
you know,
your post is reaching what,
like five,
10 percent of the actual audience that
signed up to see your posts and Oh,
you want to reach more,
pay US money,
right?
That's,
that's inevitably where we end up on any
of this shit is that eventually they
hook you and then they find a way to
monetize.
What do you,
how do you feel about bitcoin?
How do you feel about electronic
currency and love it.
Love it.
Super Cool.
Fascinating.
Right?
I think,
oh yeah,
I don't,
I,
I'm not an expert,
but I think that money is super low tech
right now.
Money socks right now,
like this idea that there's this
intermediary body that needs to sit in
between you and I,
if we want to exchange money that that's
bizarre in today's Day and age.
I mean I can send you email that can be
encrypted and here's how,
you know,
it's fucked.
They have all the money
deal is rigged.
It's messed up.
What they're providing is really not
that big of a deal.
Are they storing,
what do they do?
Their processing a bunch of things
mostly in computers today.
And that's
what bitcoin proved.
Bitcoin proved it because bitcoin was
able to process transactions on an
enormous scale that was bigger than a,
than an independent institution and they
were able to do it in a,
uh,
in a,
in a fashion that's completely secure
and they were able to do it for free
without any kind of venture capital.
Right?
If he didn't like you,
think about the fees you paid or how big
the banks or go to any city.
The biggest skyscrapers or the big
banks,
right?
Insurance companies,
financial institutions,
crooks,
all the crooks in their big fucking
capital.
I mean,
you think about a bitcoin came out and
out and all those guys,
but in a way because it said you don't,
you don't need to take all this money to
achieve the transaction to achieve the
end game,
you know.
So,
uh,
I mean,
um,
yeah,
I'm a big fan of alternative currencies
in general.
I don't know if it's going to be bitcoin
or something else.
We're probably at a super early point
right now with it and it's,
uh,
it's going to be,
you know,
it's hard at any time when you're
looking at something in its earliest
form to see the end game to see where it
ends up.
But uh,
you know,
when the first,
like for example,
when the first iphone jumped on the
scene,
I'll never forget that moment you before
that,
the devices before that and after that,
how much they changed in an instant.
And so I feel like once when there's
some big dynamic moment that that
bitcoin is able to achieve or
alternative currencies are able to
achieve some really cool feature where
we can tap watches and spend money and
we never have to pull anything out of
our pocket like the starbucks APP.
I'm using that shit all the time.
Do you,
um,
is it one of those things that pull you
scan?
So yeah.
So what it is is like you can,
you don't have to,
but you put in your favorite locations
and when it sends its proximity nearby,
you just swipe over and as a barcode and
you're done or you could just shake it.
Now the new,
the latest one you can shake and it just
brings up your payment.
And uh,
it collects your,
you know,
every 10 times you get a free drink
loyalty programs and then also gives you
free music and free apps.
I mean that starbucks did their APP,
right?
Oh,
the starbucks happens every 10 times.
You get a free one every time.
Amazing.
Yeah,
that's incredible.
Automatically uploads.
So like you'll always have,
you know,
the thing,
the thing is like in the past I've been
so reluctant to do rewards programs like
this.
So bizarre.
You're at a department store and it's
like every thousand dollars you get to
earn a dollar.
It's like Oh fuck it,
I don't care.
But this one,
they,
they made it in such a way that it's a
more convenient purchasing process.
So it's like,
oh,
I'll take the loyalty on the side to
side deal.
Not,
that's a cool way of looking at it too.
That's nice that they did that.
That's so clever.
And 10 to one,
it's like a really good ratio.
Like by 10 drinks you get one free.
That's really,
really is it 10,
10.
And you get to get whatever you want.
So that's when you go.
I'll have seven shots.
Chocolate by throwing and I know it's
not even a commensurate drank so he
could buy like five shots of Espresso
and I've done it before.
You can get a super drink and they give
you one on your birthday as well to give
you a.
because of the APP,
the APP,
just tell them they go get a free drink.
So when you're at the store you hit the
APP and then just shake it and then it
pays for the world's getting ridiculous.
How do you feel about Google glass?
Actually,
that's a good.
That's a good thing to talk about
because I feel like these are the
interim glass.
These watches interim that's going to
get you to a glass one day glasses.
Nowhere near ready for mass mass
consumption it.
Well it's $1,500
first of all,
uh,
which to some people might see,
might not seem like a huge hurdle,
but it's gigantic.
And second of all it's obtrusive.
Like I just got back from San Francisco
where there's,
you know,
glasses,
there's a huge percentage of people
wearing glass.
Didn't someone get in trouble for
driving with
them on.
I didn't hear that story,
but I think they could imagine.
I think they had to drop the case.
Right.
But the thing the guy got in trouble for
driving with the mom because they were
saying that he was using was driving.
I'm sure that's happened.
I know some bars have outlawed them
should.
Yeah,
that's fucking cool.
They have those weird cameras you can
buy that look like buttons.
They have those and they'll also have
stan hope used.
Stan hope had a,
a,
a hidden camera show for awhile and he
had glasses.
This was a long fucking time ago.
Camera.
The.
Yeah.
I want to say this isn't the nineties.
Might've been the nineties.
Doug had a really funny fucking like
hidden camera show and one of the things
he did is he had these glasses and there
just like this little center thing and
you couldn't tell.
Oh,
definitely the.
So that's.
That already exists.
Yup.
Yeah.
But anyway,
in.
Yeah,
in the case of glass I don't.
There's this really weird experience if
you,
if you own it,
you can't really wear it.
If you go out wearing that,
some people have no problem doing it,
but it becomes the whole event.
Everybody wants to ask about it or try.
It may not nuts.
Maybe not so much anymore,
but it's just not a.
there's something wrong with it.
I don't know what it's hard to pinpoint.
Right.
But if I came in here wearing glass
immediately,
you would go work.
He would have a different perception of
me.
Yes.
And I don't think we're ready to make
that kind of a statement.
I think it's going to have to look up
your glasses.
Yeah,
it'll have.
It'll have to be regular glasses and a
game.
It's got to be.
I mean,
as things get smaller and smaller,
that shouldn't be prohibitive.
Right.
Just the,
the lenses themselves though,
the bars on the side of the lenses.
Just some sort of like right now it's a
little oversized.
And you swipe it.
Yeah.
You know,
and I've done it.
Yeah,
I didn't like it.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it felt silly to me.
I don't want this thing in front of my
face.
Right?
Yeah.
And there's this prism and I actually
got the version,
but I wear sunglasses all the time.
So if I went out and I had no navigation
in my car,
I just slap these bitches on and I see
everything that's coming at me.
I see the weather up here for sure.
I mean that would be the shit.
Why haven't they done this shit?
I haven't.
They just created some dope ass Oakley
style sunglasses that have a fucking
screen in it.
Like your goddamn movie theater and I'm
driving around and all my information
you're done with your girlfriends is
right over here.
That's what.
That's what every year at target.
I think what it's going to be like.
We're all gonna have our own google
glasses,
but it's also going to have something
that broadcast is our Avatar,
so it's not going to.
We're going to feel comfortable.
You recording me because you're acting.
My face is going to be replaced with a
cat face and my voice has to be replaced
with something else.
That's just your retarded world.
No one's buying it the fuck out of here.
Some ways there's like a,
there's a,
there's a race between,
between a glass and other forms of
augmented reality to like,
uh,
like this thing I brought over here,
this little piece of cardboard,
but ultimately isn't like glasses the
most convenient to have more common
because people have all the time anyway.
Oh No,
definitely.
What is this,
Brian?
What do you got here?
This is Oakley airwaves,
which is kind of like their version of
like,
I dunno like a google glass where it
has.
It's like
a ski goggles to drive around with
those.
That is.
That's when I said that the,
the,
the privacy.
A face.
That's what I was kind of pulled up.
That it has navigation.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Back that up.
It has fucking navigation and your ski
gone.
Do you want to listen to this?
The fuck can't play that shit.
Okay.
That's the craziest thing I've ever
heard in my life.
If we can get this to work,
that's amazing.
Airways.
One point five technology that delivers
the goods straight to your brain.
So what we're seeing right now is the
speed.
How fast you're going out to the Albert
who'd vertical,
your jump analytics.
So how high you're jumping and it's
showing as you're looking down the
speed,
your air time buddy.
Tracking your phone.
You can play music with this fucking
thing.
You're getting text messages,
looking at your navigation screen,
looking at your,
you picking your music.
All dog shit music.
Jesus Christ.
I guess it's cool tech.
Better skier skiing.
Fuck
man.
How are you interacting with all that
stuff?
Um,
poorly trees.
Sonny Bono in yourself.
Left and the right.
We'll get the fucking.
Oh,
it slips off different lenses.
Yeah.
You can put on sunglasses.
Do you can go terminator style.
I think I'm just going to wear this
little mall.
That's what I'm saying.
Is this the Paparazzi glasses thing that
I was talking about?
Like it's going to be the star wars now.
He's had a really big one that went over
your whole face that pitches smart with
that idea.
This is amazing man.
But if you're a skier,
ski Brian.
Yeah,
go skiing.
I used to be in ski club.
Dude.
Ski with one of these bitches on God
down.
That'd be cool as fuck.
That's amazing.
Oakley.
Fuck you.
Oakley.com.
Airwave,
if you want to watch it.
If you're listening to.
Cool.
That's amazing.
What a great idea.
It's only a matter of time before
someone did that.
That's way better than Google.
$600.
I ain't had.
Yeah,
that's not bad.
That's way better than Google glass
sometimes.
Feel like when I watched those promos
though,
that it's bullshit and you should be you
doing it.
Well,
you know that's what you do.
That's what I do,
man.
I take the bullshit out of it.
What's been the most disappointing
product that you had to do that too?
Wow.
That was your one product that you
sometimes like trying to think right
now.
Somebody's like,
oh,
I hope sometimes it's so shit that I,
I wouldn't even want to give it the
exposure,
you know,
that's smart.
Like what?
Give me an example of that so we can
give him some exposure.
Some guy.
I hate doing this though.
Some guys.
It's like the dream.
They got like a pro product.
Fuck them.
They're shitty ideas.
One guy had,
this was back in the day and when a lot
of people were into like,
like little docking stands for your
phones and shit like that.
And some guy had one kind of like
essentially glued onto your phone like
this sloppy material.
I regretted it immediately.
I was upset.
So that's an example.
So you put it on your phone?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
how'd you cleaned it off?
Like rubbing on?
Yeah,
that's it.
So glue was glorious thing.
Shitty gluten.
No,
I mean,
let me think.
Chinese big time stuff like.
Oh,
or a laptop?
That was dog shit.
Oh Wow.
You want to go there?
I do want to go there.
I was upset with my playstation four
really come because the controllers are
not very durable.
I had within,
within a few weeks I had the,
uh,
the rubber from the thumb sticks
starting to degenerate.
I posted a video.
It has almost a million views.
Oh my goodness.
I tell you when I'm sick of Berenger
mixers,
I found out that Berenger as a company,
I've always used [inaudible] because I
always go to the budget and budget
stuff.
German brands.
It was created Germany,
right?
Or something like that.
I think they just use a German.
So hilarious.
Brian's done.
His research pro.
You always use German.
Wait,
what?
I don't know if it's that.
I'm pretty sure it's not German.
There's been.
No,
actually it was just the first mixer
every got.
Sorry,
I just went with it,
but I had to.
I haven't had to replace,
like I've spent more on mixers in the
last five years and then I researched
it.
Podcast mics,
stairs.
I just had to replace my third one and
this time I went with the Yamaha,
just whatever.
But uh,
I found out that there's like class,
like in the past they've had lawsuits
and stuff are pretty much they just take
a good concert and just copy it was
shitty parts,
like the first version of like when you
go get a,
a fake iphone in China,
it's the exact same shit.
But like I,
I went to guitar center the other day
and they're like,
yeah,
we uh,
we stopped carrying all of or because
this and I just now found out after
spending so much money on Berenger and
having so much shit fry out.
Do you want to do so?
Yamaha is a good move though,
right?
Omaha is pretty good.
There's something with an m I can't
remember.
Like Moki Makie.
Makie supposedly is what everyone else
loves.
How many times have you burned out?
What is,
what do we have here?
What is that?
This is a parent in church and the
headphone,
but yeah,
the,
I've replaced three,
uh,
like 400,
$500 mixers in the last two years.
Three years down the headphone Jack just
went out like the yesterday or second
headphone Jack headphone jacks went out
all the time.
They all fucking suck.
I'm sorry.
Not a candidate even leaving these mics
are the shit.
I just want to say that.
These are the statements.
You just heard the opinion only that of
Brian's my opinion do not represent the
rest of this podcast.
So in Gen,
in general though,
products have gotten a lot better.
They have to,
they've gotten just like market wide.
You can't get away with a nod.
Nope.
It's this too much.
Too much pr now.
Total exposure exposure.
Like that's one thing I fucking love.
And one of the reasons why I wanted to
have you on is the kind of videos that
you do and there's a lot of other that
are doing them now.
There's so comprehensive.
It would have never existed on a network
television show.
Like even like the,
like when you used to have the whole
tech tv days,
which was excellent.
I love the screensavers.
I love that they didn't have the time to
do what you're doing and specific to
that device.
You don't have to worry about,
you know,
oh,
I have to be off the air in six minutes.
That's when the commercial goes.
We have to go to break.
There's no break.
There's no.
All that stuff is dog shit.
That's a dumb.
With that silent movies,
you're doing a puppet show.
You might as well be shown this was a
real monster girl.
No,
it's not.
Okay.
You can't use the rubber claymation
anymore.
It's 2014 and you can't keep reviewing
tech items on television.
So essentially what's going on as the
Internet has created a platform for you
guys to completely change the technology
review market.
Right?
And make it super interactive.
Like say,
if you're thinking about getting a new
iphone,
you go online,
go to cnet,
go to your site,
go to all these different sites and
you'll just hit review after review
after review informed detailed in depth
reviews that many times the guy will
say,
I've had this phone for the past five
days,
fucking with it.
Here are my thoughts.
You're just not gonna.
Get that anywhere else?
No,
it's the platform.
The platform has enabled that to happen.
Like like it's enabled so many new forms
of entertainment to happen.
Like this podcast is.
For example,
if somebody would have given us a show,
not a fucking chance in hell,
a radio show.
Now bringing this guy with me.
We're gonna.
Yeah.
He started shit because it's kind of
cute because of the.
Because of the.
Even the way you said that,
like in the old days,
old media,
somebody had to give you something.
You know what I mean?
Right now you go out and get it.
Well,
the old days someone had to hire you for
a show.
That's what I mean.
There's no way you had to.
There was a predetermined time slot,
like if you had a radio station,
all you have on that radio station is
the times that you're broadcasting.
We could simultaneously broadcast.
I mean we could if we wanted to.
Brian and I got together and said,
you know what,
let's start a fucking podcast empire.
Let's right everybody that we can
contact online,
have those centers.
We could start hiring people before,
you know,
we get up 50 podcast going on at the
same time just dumping them out into the
Internet.
You don't have to have a 24 hour time
period where you know,
frosty.
Heidi and frank are from eight to 10 and
then after that it's fucking conway and
steckler.
You don't have to have that anymore.
No.
And brings it.
Brings up a lot of deficiencies in the
traditional media model that now that
everything is same,
everything is essentially on demand and
it,
it honestly feels strange for me to plan
my day around a live event and about
watching commercials.
But you want to fucking throw up in your
pants like,
what are you showing me?
Why is the program stopped vs Horse
Shit?
To be honest with you,
commercials don't need to be as bad as
they are.
Now Look at Art Formula Joe.
Now we might do it a little long,
but what if we were advertising Coca
Cola in 30 seconds so we can do whatever
the fuck we want.
I would watch that.
But here's the thing,
like when the super bowl happens,
everyone has come to replenish glycogen
corn
syrup.
If you put a frog inside that can of
cook for two weeks,
coke bad for you.
Fuck yeah,
it's bad.
I was living in a city you fuck face.
How about coconut smile and shut the
fuck up pitch.
It's old school.
Yeah.
Um,
but they don't.
The only reason why that works is
because that forced that,
like they're constantly trying to get me
to do ads in the middle of a podcast.
Yeah,
definitely.
Every new ad that's like one of the
first things that comes up.
It's a debate.
It's like they want to interrupt the
show and insert ads.
It's not a,
that's not an option.
It's a super stupid crappy models and
work.
No.
It doesn't and defensive.
It's a holdover.
It's a holdover from a time that doesn't
exist anymore.
It's like,
well,
let's just take the platform that
existed and and bolted onto this new
thing instead of developing something
from the ground up that fits with this
language.
This is a whole new language.
I even feel this way about indi
individual social networks.
Like I feel like youtube has a language.
Facebook hasn't language.
Twitter has a language.
Instagram that sort of when you're a
content producer,
you sort of feel like all those places
at the same because you're broadcasting
to all of them,
but ultimately more often than not,
those users,
our platform independent,
they have a place where they like to get
at you more than one other place and
that becomes their habit and so since
their consumption model is unique,
so say your people who people who viewed
this podcast on youtube versus who
listened to the audio only versus who.
Those are all independent people,
all with their their own mindset and
trying to.
Trying to figure out the right way of
interacting with all those groups is
something that big brands are trying to
do now through their,
their,
their social experiments and et cetera.
So,
uh,
when,
when people come and talk to me,
brands or advertisers or whoever it
might be,
it's like,
listen,
we need to build something from the
ground up native to this platform.
Don't bring me something from somewhere
else.
This is not a national ad campaign.
This is 850,000
very sophisticated viewers with a super
high sensitivity to bullshit,
right?
Because they're not used to getting it
here.
It's not getting any of it.
They're not getting any of it about your
own life.
People who are hosting podcasts will
tell you the truth about their own
personal fuck off.
Exactly.
And so that's it.
It's a,
it's a really unique proposition.
Huge value,
huge value for a brand.
In some ways I feel like this whole
marketplace is heavily undervalued.
When you compare a CPM figures like from
the traditional media world to this
world,
these people are more fucking dedicated
there.
They're loyal.
They know that you're kicking them the
real deal.
Unbox therapy is not going to lie.
You're not allowing your deep,
your eyes and you're also,
you're.
You're deep into discovering the flaws
which is actually essential to the
development process,
like for to ensure that you still have a
job and that these companies create an
innovative,
but it might be painful for them.
They might not enjoy some of your
criticisms,
but it's.
It's critical.
I'll give you an example right now.
Please do live example,
example.
Samsung.
Samsung keeps making these shitty ass
chargers.
Okay?
Yes.
Look at this damn thing.
This is just the charger for their
watch.
This is a beautiful looking device,
right?
That's the charger.
Installed the charger.
Joe,
go for it,
bitch.
You know who also done that in the past?
Sony used to do that shit all the time.
If they're like Bluetooth headsets and
you say,
oh,
you mean proprietary stuff?
Well these are.
These are all going to be proposed.
That's what you gotta do every night
before bed.
You're not doing that.
You had a few drinks.
Well,
that's why the new Apple Watch is going
to be a dude.
I'm coordinators.
Fuck no,
no,
no.
I'll be on heroin.
I'll do this.
I'm not saying you can't do it,
but that's not a pleasurable experience.
You're so funny that you would like it
to be just like a regular usb.
You remember what I said before about
opening up an apple laptop.
That breath of fresh air that you get
it.
You can't measure it.
It just keeps you liking in using the
device is sort of like their keyboards
and the mice.
They're so clean and everything is just
like I want.
I just want to look at the damn thing.
You know what I mean?
If a beautiful thing will always be more
attractive.
I forgot the damn charger for the LG g
watch,
but no worries.
Lg on the other hand,
the entire back is a magnet.
All you do is you just drop it.
Lg Winds better.
Apple's new watch.
You just lay it down on the of course,
but the minute you laid down on the
counter that charger.
Hold on.
How's that possible?
Go ahead.
Hey.
Well,
a lot of you could do this right now.
You can go to best buy and buy these
things that fit on the back of your mind
and some phones you need to buy anything
is already ci enabled.
Yeah.
Where you could just lay down on the mat
and we'll show a map.
A specific part thought you were saying
it charges in the air.
I like apple is a watch supposedly has
it where you could just lay it down on
this.
Matt,
you know,
I'll tell you my one criticism of the
mat.
The problem with that with the mat is
traveling,
traveling with a Goddamn Matt.
Yeah.
Unless it's becomes as big as the iphone
and then Hook,
just have that mat which is probably
gonna have if,
if,
if it's gonna take awhile,
but starbucks actually are starting to
implement ci enabled surfaces so it will
happen but it's definitely not there
yet.
And in the meantime the little charger
for this LG is,
it's super thin and it's about the size
of the watch and they,
they can connect if you put them
together in your bag.
So because it has a magnet,
but I had to watch before this,
the galaxy gear.
Okay.
This is the gear live.
The naming conventions are terrible.
That's one of the hardest parts of the
job actually.
Just getting the names right.
Well it's better than like the old days
off model numbers like.
Yeah,
I guess so.
But anyway,
the galaxy gear had this wacky thing
that strapped around the whole device.
It was shit,
it screwed up the experience for me.
And I think that ruined the device if
the UI.
So Ui doesn't end here.
User interface.
Uh,
yeah,
exactly.
Or,
or you,
he used going to fuck or user or user
experience in general.
It's a lot of people assume like if
you're a developer,
you're building it for this and that's
it.
No,
this is Ui,
this aluminum or,
or you eat it's user experience.
The whole experience is encompassed in
the way you interact with the damn thing
to do.
Selling a wine connoisseur who sound
like one of those dudes is really in a
certain grade.
I think I'm getting fired up right now.
I like this guy.
I agree with you 100 percent and I think
that also what were saying before is
that your,
these criticisms,
this,
this very detailed review that you'll do
about these products is super critical,
super critical for the development and
will be hiring you.
Oh,
I get lots of interesting to get offers
to join apple.
Tell you.
Shut the fuck up.
Just come over here.
I'm sure.
Shut the fuck.
I'm sure apple is not a huge fan of mine
because I did some leaking of different
components.
How dare you do that?
You've got it offline from China.
Yeah.
It's on the Internet.
It's out there on the ocean.
So deal with it.
Probably not a big fan of mine.
It's funny.
They did their keynote.
I didn't.
I had leaked,
um,
the IPAD air chassis,
the entire body before it came out.
So I had the entire form factor,
right?
It was on Forbes.
They get mad at you.
No,
they didn't.
I never heard a word about it,
but in the keynote they addressed it
like the big keynote that everyone was
watching.
They're like,
we think you guys might be familiar with
this next device,
like Tim Cook addressed it,
so I was like,
did you feel like certain amount of
power on the radar?
Ooh,
did something he made?
No,
I didn't.
I didn't really because I feel like
these things are going to,
they're going to leak out regardless.
There's just because of guys like you.
It's like saying people,
it's almost going to murder someone
regardless because of a murderer I
guess.
You know,
I guess I guess you're right about that,
but I,
I honestly,
I'm,
I'm much more interested in the demand
for it.
Like why do people care so much?
That's another thing that shows about
how our attachment to these devices.
It's insane that I put out a video like
that and he's like,
you know,
I don't know 2 million views or it's on
Forbes.
It's,
it was,
it was everywhere.
Like it was posted.
All I had to google notifications turned
on for whenever it was getting.
I was getting a news notification every
time my name was being used and we're
just going off like it was on all these
different sites that we're embedding my
video and they're uh,
they're doing it because investors want
to make adjustments to their plans
preemptively based on the,
based on what they like.
No,
I mean not the review.
I mean like the,
the leak.
So they see the IPAD air chassis before
it actually comes out and you go home
and people going like that chassis or
people are going to buy that chess.
Do you review when there's a leak?
You give opinions on the leak?
Yeah,
I can share.
I compare it to the old one,
like I do physical dimensions.
I pulled a measuring tape out.
Have you ever known of anyone that's
given some sort of review and it's
actually changed the final product
because they listened to what people
were saying about a leak product and we
hit the bricks.
It can be a disaster.
Good question.
Probably like on kickstarter or
something like that,
but not in a big.
Don't feel like they would ever let you
know.
You know what I mean,
but,
but I think brands are definitely paying
attention to the chatter they need to
and the market research is going deep
now.
You know,
they,
they invest way too much money in
creating these things to take a risk
that everyone's going to hate it.
So.
And a guy like you is a direct line to
that because.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm tapped into the pipeline.
You're doing this all day long.
Access to the vein.
Yeah.
This is my thing.
When I used to do cameras,
I used to,
when those little baby video cameras
used to be,
became really popular,
whatever those were called.
Remember used to have a couple of them
are hd ones with the SD cards and a
Kodak had one and I did a really bad
review on one of codex,
a little exactly what you're telling me.
And it was because of low,
uh,
went during low lighting and stuff like
that.
It had a bunch of fucked up problems.
Kodak,
Kodak contact me and they actually did a
firmware upgrade based on just wondering
if there's an example.
That's tremendous.
Yeah.
Look,
that's a super valuable resource for a
company.
Definitely they're not going to get that
kind of objectivity from the people that
work there and it was also a hierarchy
with managers and people that work under
the managers and maybe the managers a
dick and he doesn't want to listen to
Mike's Advice and Mike,
you know Mike is kind of soft spoken,
but it's got really good ideas.
There's a lot of that social shit that
goes on to incorporate something that
doesn't get talked about is the is the
cultural aspect,
like the vast majority of this stuff
comes from halfway across the world.
Right?
We all know that.
I don't know what I can say on this,
but are you withholding information
information?
I'm just.
He doesn't want to burden.
There's A.
Yeah.
I'm not going to just try a way to name
any brands,
but some rhymes at ams young.
Some are completely out of touch with
the way life works over here.
Okay.
In America,
I see.
That makes sense and it shines through
and certain decision making when it
comes not only to products but to the
way they market those products to the
way they communicate with press or the
way they communicate with their own
people.
It's um,
I've,
I've been in some certain circumstances
where it's been very foreign that makes
a tremendous amount of sap and seems
like,
of course it seems obvious,
but everyone wants to pretend that a
user experience and in Asia is the same
thing that we're going to want here.
You know,
like how many.
Okay.
I'm going to go on a bit of an android
rent.
This is a nexus five.
Okay.
Beautiful phone.
This is a google a google product.
This is the unadulterated android
experience.
The Way Google intended.
I don't know if they would have attended
that wallpaper.
No,
they probably didn't.
Actually,
that's a good friend of mine.
Please don't say anything.
I don't even know what it is.
I'm just fucking around.
Okay.
No,
no,
you're right.
It wouldn't be stock.
That's not a stock wallpaper.
But um,
uh,
so they have the best developers in the
world.
If you're a bad ass developer,
where are you going to work?
Apple,
Google,
Amazon,
I mean,
whatever.
Somewhere in silicon valley,
somewhere in the Pacific northwest,
you'll be all set.
If you're the best developer in the
world,
you go in Asia,
is that your number one priority?
Is that where you're going to go?
Like Asian chick and heroin,
you Japan in September,
so I'll let you know so,
but anyway,
here's the.
Here's the problem,
the R and d that goes into that
software.
Extensive,
so much money,
so many smart people,
right?
What does Samsung do?
Three weeks,
they overhauled a motherfucker.
Come on,
how are you going to take something that
took that long to develop and you're
going to skin it and you're going to
change everything about it is three
weeks while no,
I'm exaggerating.
Oh,
if you pick up a samsung device,
it's not the same as an LG device.
Not the same as a Motorola device.
It's not the same.
There's this fragmentation and that's in
those,
because in the tech space,
it's called the f word by the way,
fragmented for,
they call it the f word.
It's a big deal because they decide to
add their own user interface.
They're old shit.
Samsung has their own thing that they
do.
What is it called?
Samsung is called Touchwiz.
Yeah.
What's that?
You're not touching my dick.
That's what I hear.
Now you have.
You have the ring,
right?
So that's the original operating system
and everything.
Do you.
Is it night and day difference?
Because I've always used I guess a skin
version.
Balls.
You San Francisco Mall.
Fuck all that shit.
He's got his hardcore dude.
He's super hardcore.
He's like Antonopoulos.
Remember Antonopoulos that he breaks
everything down.
Roots it and yeah.
Here's the thing.
It's like I just really believe in the
intelligence level of the original
developers and I can't imagine how they
sleep at night knowing that most
people's interpretation of android is a
galaxy device.
Get one of these next disease.
They're like smashed.
You're sitting there.
This is their art form and they're
sitting there putting all of this energy
into simple decisions like the shape of
an icon.
You know what I mean?
Design and then someone goes and goes,
I will build a better gun,
will be happy face.
No big deal is.
It doesn't make any sense.
It would be like you'd get some
beautiful painting and you send it half
way across the world to Asia and tell
them,
do what you want with it.
Right.
We never do that with any other kind of
art.
That's interesting.
So you're,
you're accepting it as an art form.
I guess you're right,
it's created some.
Creates it.
Someone draws the whole thing up,
man.
Yeah.
With the,
this uh,
the guy behind this isn't Mathias
Duarte.
He was at Google Io.
He's their lead designer on the uh,
and,
and it's about to get overhauled as
well.
The new version is called L and it's
even more beautiful in my opinion,
than,
than what this four point four point
four that I'm working on right now.
But here's another problem.
I'm using four point four point four.
That's the latest android Ios.
What's that called?
Um,
it's always candy Kit Kat,
Kat.
Uh,
the next,
the dispersion,
the specific iteration of this software
is you will not find it on any galaxy
device right now,
right.
The updates and this,
this,
Holy Shit,
this is a big
discussion because we're going to
involve the carriers.
Now.
The carriers are really to blame for
enabling this process.
So android in the beginning of Andrew
has had to meet so many sacrifices to
catch up and one of those sacrifices is
letting carriers dictate how they're
going to implement these devices.
Verizon,
atnt,
etc.
So you buy a phone from verizon,
there's a bunch of bullshit from boot it
up and you see a verisign logo.
The whole juSt discussed dude,
in some cases they put the logo right on
the outside of the phone.
There was a galaxy,
I think the [inaudible] had verizon on
the button on the front,
tiny little button strapped with
verizon.
So those are,
those are changes that the carriers want
to make because they're hoping to build
their own ecosystems and capitalize
more.
The carriers are,
they're not in an innovative business.
They're in,
in an accounting business of finding a
way to just use you for a few more
pennies.
You can do a little ting spot right now
if you,
except for the pockets.
They're clever.
Now,
when an economy moves in that direction
where their objective is just a pinch
more pennies,
what happens to innovation takes a
fucking nosedive because knows I'll
fucking nosedive it does.
And because all of a sudden now the
bottom line is effected by someone,
some nerd with a,
uh,
a report in front of them saying,
just get rid of that,
you know,
whatever.
It's made through subtraction,
not addition.
That's fascinating.
That's a really interesting way to look
at it.
I really liked the idea that it's a
piece of art.
I love that you were looking at it that
way because you're absolutely correct.
I think of it as technology,
but it is something that's created
anything created as art and it's
certainly beautiful.
You know,
I love like scrolling through.
I love how android,
like my galaxy note three has like a
different thing when I'm flipping
through the pages.
I like animation or something.
I love the fucking pen,
I love that they figured out how to do
that.
And you're doing,
you're using the pen on a regular basis.
Well,
I'm a comic notes.
I knew that part.
I'm a big.
I think there's something about
physically writing things that there is
a different impact.
So.
And then I upload them to um,
uh,
to evernote.
So I have the actual note itself on my
iphone as well.
Definitely.
So yeah.
Oh dude.
Evernote is fucking fantastic.
Yeah.
But what I really love about it is that
you take like,
like a note like this year.
Yeah.
This is a note that I wrote on on the
note.
Wow.
Decent writing yet.
Not bad.
Right.
So you could put it here and it comes
out like,
you know,
it's good man.
Yellow paper.
Cool.
It's really big.
Can you see that you're not gonna be
able to see it because of the phone
itself that just the glare but
handwritten notes come off.
So responsive.
The pen is.
So it is definitely.
I agree.
Any handwritten note that you make?
It looks really like alex ohanian did a.
He made a little reddit alien on the
note.
We put it up.
I mean,
you,
you do things with it.
There's no doubt that the
pen is a far more.
He has far more precision than your
fingertip.
Yeah,
no doubt about it.
So,
uh,
there's all kinds of industries that are
affected by that.
Comedy is one as you,
as you said,
but also like artists for example,
are doing insane illustrations on the
note.
Like,
like top quality stuff on there.
It's the apps that exist,
like a different sketching out.
What do you got there?
So it's something for an ounce of
sketching up.
Yeah.
This is actually an art app and it's
great because it has,
it's called color box hd and it has like
every single pen you could possibly
imagine that uses the photoshop if you
have a favorite pen that you actually
like.
Kerrick.
Yeah.
So now when you draw with a pen of
stylists,
what kind of stylist to use?
So you have a specific one.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean I just got this app recently
because I've been trying to draw more on
my ipad.
I've been trying to use my ipad more.
Actually.
I have two ipads and I've been trying to
just carry this around.
Stiff a laptop lately,
a surface,
microsoft's version of it,
you know,
it just released this whole thing where
they,
you could trade in your old mac book air
or and get like $650 credit towards
their new surface,
which is like their version of this
mixed with a laptop or a mac book air.
I've been trying to see if I could just
use this more.
Tony hinchcliffe doesn't even have a
computer.
Everything that he uses is just on an
ipad.
That's ridiculous.
I know that when I'm trying to see if I
can get to though because I love this
thing.
There's no.
One of my favorite things at tech.
Just bond that's a hasn't been delivered
yet,
but I'm looking forward to it.
I bought a mechanical keyboard.
Yeah,
I want to hear it.
You just got a major street cred in the
tech world for doing that.
Yes.
You did.
Oh nice.
And I missed that.
Of course you do.
Yeah.
It comes back to user experience in
general.
Well,
I think about user experience is very
critical.
I think about things that I enjoy.
I drive a manual transmission most of
the time.
I like that.
I like shifting the gears like wow,
I'm a part of it and an enjoyable
experience.
Tactile feel the snicks of the gear.
I mean I wouldn't want to do it if I was
stuck in traffic all the time.
Right.
But if I'm not stuck in traffic,
I know I'm not going to be driving that
car and I think there's something to
that tactile experience for sure.
Like there's a lot of,
there's a lot of pushback happening now.
Digital interfaces,
people miss all kinds.
Like mechanical keyboards are a perfect
example.
It's also an issue with cars.
Electronic steering,
electric steering is the new thing in
sports cars.
Really?
Yeah.
What people don't like about.
There's a,
there's actually a blowback and more
people are buying older sports cars that
have no steering,
no power steering like the old
porsche's.
Wow.
The old porsches were super light car
and they had manual steering.
So you turn the wheel,
you felt everything.
Yeah,
you're connected to those front wheels,
like a go cart and the new ones are so
totally electric,
so it's sort of like a video game.
There's no difference.
Like if you have a hard turn or if you
have an easy turn,
there's no difference in the amount of
correcting.
It's just going same as the
transmissions.
A I drove a gtr which has a.
Oh yeah,
the electronic transmission that's a can
can behave,
can,
can shift more efficiently than any
human,
but it's like,
what is that really about,
you know,
what are we really,
what are we really connected to?
Like is it,
do we really need to go that split
second faster or do we get more out of
it?
Like you said,
through feeling more of it.
It's hard to really pinpoint if you have
an old school muscle car and it's an
automatic,
you're missing out on half the fun of
having an old school muscle car.
Right,
right,
right.
Shifting those gears yourself is I had
an automatic barracuda and I hated it.
I hated the fact that it was automatic.
You used to drive me crazy,
but that's how they,
when they were building it,
they were saying there's no way to put
this engine with a manual transfer.
They're just knuckleheads.
but I talked to a guy who I was going to
have it fixed up before I want.
I want them to selling it and getting
rid of it.
cause it was just.
There was a negative connotation
probably associated because of the
automatic transmission.
It was because of the bill.
I had a bill for a television show and
there was always behind the scenes drama
from the people that made the show with
the builders of the car itself.
oh,
it's a lot of nightmares.
Shit that I don't want to get into.
Right,
right,
right.
The big nightmare shit was that I don't
trust those things.
I got it home and as I was pulling into
my driveway,
the suspension,
I say yes,
I was just on the highway 10 minutes ago
going 65,
70 miles an hour and a a death man,
which would have been horrendous if that
blew out.
I would have crashed into other people.
Who knows what,
if I was responsible for someone else
being injured or killed,
I would have felt horrible just to drive
this cool thing.
yeah,
it's true.
I sometimes get that feeling about a
fast cars in general,
like I feel like home great
responsibility.
Like you drive that car and you get in
an accident and is completely not your
fault.
And then he goes,
look at the dickhead in the,
in the fast car.
Absolutely.
And they should.
I guess they should because it does say
something about,
uh,
I guess it says something about your
personality.
Well,
it auto insurers would say it does.
It also says something about your
ability to control something.
And The problem with buying a fast car
is that they don't have any gauge
whatsoever on your ability to control
it.
No.
Say like tanner foust,
who's a race car driver,
the guy and tie him,
yet that guy walks into a corvette
dealership and buys a corvette.
You can be rest assured he knows how to
handle that,
but there's a lot of people that get in
those things.
They hit the gas,
they just spin and,
and slamming.
I know sometimes I feel like it is kind
of bizarre that they let people walk out
of the shop with 500 horsepower more.
How about in the shitty chassis?
Shelby mustangs?
I fucking love the shelby mustangs.
Right?
Um,
they're,
they're not that good.
They're like,
they have a solid rear axle there.
There.
I mean it's a massive piece of
engineering to control that solid rear
axle.
But you could get one for like $50,000
and it has 670 fucking horsepower.
That's insane.
It is.
And it's so fun to drive.
They're one of the most fun american
cars ever created.
The new shelby mustangs.
They're not the best
handling car.
They don't break the best brakes are
mushy.
That dog shit.
Right?
If you get a convertible,
you might as well be driving around in a
fucking wetland,
sanya noodle bouncing.
But the tactile field that you get from
those is so fun though.
The engine,
the wine of the fucking supercharger
whine.
I mean,
I think sometimes efficiency is boring.
Fuck yeah.
Prius is suck.
Yeah.
those are boring as shit.
Not,
not just fuel efficiency,
but efficiency in general.
Like think about coffee for example.
You can,
you could find some crazy way to
precision engineer some coffee bean and,
and get it into a form factor that could
ship to you already made,
but you talked to any coffee connoisseur
and it's like they got to get the beans.
They got a roast the beans,
they got to put them in the grinder.
You know,
part of the experience is not just the
consumption of it,
but everything leading up to it.
Yeah.
Actually,
I heard you talking about addiction,
uh,
last night.
And I was thinking,
and we were talking about ritual on the
podcast last night.
Yes.
And,
um,
I really,
it seems to me that at least in my
business,
the ritual is the thing.
Yeah,
so wanting is way better than the
having.
It's a lot of it.
I think it's better than having because
you want to know what happens when you.
When you have something is you
immediately start to think about whether
or not you should still have it.
You know,
iT has to enter your mind at some point.
I think that's an attitude though.
I think that's a matter of focus because
there are things that I have that you'll
never get rid of or feel like that that
you'll never get rid of my car.
I mean I might one day sell if you will,
one day.
I'd love it.
I've had it for a couple of years.
I'm not saying you can't love products,
I'm just saying it's like a
relationship.
It just changes you when you see a
really hot girl and you start to hit it
off or whatever.
That's a certain type of magic that
can't ever happen again.
That's true.
Yeah.
You can never recreate that and some
people go their whole lives trying to
get to that first.
Hi.
I have a friend who did that for the
longest time.
Eventually got married and had a kid,
but one of the things he said,
he goes,
I just want a lot of beginnings.
There you go.
He goes,
I don't like relationships,
man.
He goes,
in the beginning,
everybody's trying so hard.
Everybody.
Everybody's so excited,
everybody's so friendly,
and he goes and then all of a sudden
bItches are yelling overnights.
I just want a bunch of beginnings where
people like,
but not not to make this,
not to pull this back and make it super
nerdy,
but it's the same thing here,
right?
My channel,
it's called unbox therapy for a reason
that there is some kind of intangible
thing that happens when you get some new
thing.
Yeah,
I think there's definitely something to
it,
but there's also what you people would
say it's material fetishism that you're
definitely constantly obsessing about
materials.
Maybe you should go for a hike,
go out and look at the birds.
See the meadows.
Except that except that the eventual
futures.
Everybody lying down on a couch with a
vr headset interacting with a world
isn't real.
I think that's possible.
I.
I think it's probably inevitable.
I mean,
scientists believe that may be going on
right now.
That might be the world we actually has
written.
It's just so complex and so good.
Oh,
really?
Could be this.
I wanted to talk about this cardboard
over here.
What is it?
Getting back to vr.
There's just.
I could tell you were excited when I
first picked it up because it's a piece
of bark or something inside of it.
There's nothing inside of it.
Oh,
for real.
let's play this game.
Guess what it is.
Okay,
but you can't open it though.
It stays this way.
Yeah.
You know nothing of this.
I know.
Absolutely not.
Okay.
To me,
I would assume there's like a memory
card in here or a screen or something
that you're protecting.
Okay.
That this is the shipping material.
That's what I would assume.
This is the first thing they gave us at
io before they gave us any watches and
this is the world's cheapest vr headset
right here.
Okay.
There you go.
That's what it is.
So it opens up,
it opens up.
There's lenses inside of it.
You build it and it.
There's a place that the phone sits
there,
and this is nfc enabled.
Your phone sits on that,
so your phone mounts inside of here and
the nfc on the back of the phone will
launch an application and that
application on the screen then is going
to display a,
uh,
through the lenses in interactivity
similar to oculus rift,
but right here with a piece of cardboard
for $5.
See,
that's what happens,
man.
Someone gets cocky,
they spent billions of dollars to
helping oculus rift.
Someone comes along and says,
not only fuck you,
fuck you with cardboard.
Here's google.
Google did say fuck you with cardboard.
But the real reason for that is because
vr is going to be tough to sell in the
long,
in the long run.
It's too expensive,
it's too elaborate.
And so developers won't get on board.
So this is a development material,
a development kit,
so that,
uh,
the imaginations of developers
everywhere,
they can,
uh,
they can check out what their app might
be like if they did a virtual reality
version of it.
So for folks who are listening to this,
which is most people,
most people download this and listened
to it,
right.
What we're
looking@islikesayifyoueverorderabookonamazon.com
and
it
comes
in a
little
box,
it was very similar to that.
Or maybe back when used to buy cds.
Yup.
You buy a cd on amazon that would get
delivered to you.
Maybe you still do that.
Um,
that would look like that.
It's a small,
maybe like 10 by eight.
Ten by eight probably.
Yeah.
Something like that just looks like a
piece of cardboard.
Have you done this yet?
Nope.
Can we do it now?
I don't know how smooth it's going to
be.
We'll just know that we'll talk about
other shit while you do it,
but let's just check it out.
Let's see how long it takes.
Let's do it.
Here we go.
I am completely fascinated and I'm sure
we can hashtag think of things to talk
about.
Hashtag cardboard a.
It's a g.ceo/cardboard,
I believe is the site if you want to
know more about it.
So lewis is opening this stuff and um,
there's my good things in there,
uh,
for,
for folks who are listening magnet as
well,
a controls your interactivity with the
device.
So you click by touching this magnet.
Whoa.
Okay.
So what is god here is?
He's unfolded the amazon box.
It looks like an amazon,
but I need scissors guys.
Oh,
do we have.
Oh no,
I don't.
This is perforated.
Of course it does show scissors,
but I don't think I need to.
Yeah,
let's get the scissors.
Let's not fuck this up.
This is the first time.
I'm sure we have scissors here.
That's how we cut our butter.
So this,
this is cut her butter.
Oh,
perfect.
So he's taking this apart right now.
He's a exclusive by the way,
is it?
No,
I don't think so.
No.
Okay.
So I'm gonna.
Pretend it is.
Some other developers.
Why?
To me bro?
Probably did it.
You know how this works,
but it's a,
it's a mass media exclusive right now.
Um,
so he's,
he's cutting this,
um,
this box open and inside the box or
inside this folded up piece of
cardboard,
there's lenses to that looked like those
little instamatic things.
What are those things called?
The,
you press that button and those,
those.
No,
you know,
it's sort of like a polaroid,
but you remember those old school
things?
We had press and there will be a picture
of a dinosaur and you'd look at it.
Ooh,
viewmaster.
Yeah,
very much like a viewmaster lenses,
but I'm assuming they're a high quality
lens.
It's just embedded in this plastic
because they look pretty slick.
Does it look good?
I don't,
I'm not supposed to be looking at
distance.
Oh yeah.
We'll put this all together.
Going through the user experience or
not.
I'm not,
I'm just,
I'm a little bit perplexed right now to
insert.
I think you should have to build this
google cardboard.
So good idea.
Is there any,
um,
directions the directions are only
what's on there and a finished product.
Take care.
Assemble.
Insert the numbered tabs into the
corresponding slots at four,
four,
three,
six,
two of the salt.
So everything's numbered.
That's interesting how they did it.
Oh,
you know what?
In the meantime I'm going to hop on the
wifi.
Would this device.
So it's ready to go?
Um,
yeah.
This is not good for a podcast.
No,
not at all.
I told you we'll try it out after.
Yeah,
we'll try it out after and we'll uh,
we'll post a quick video here.
Yeah.
Here.
Yeah,
we could do that.
We can do a quick video experimentation,
but the role here is not only to say
fuck you to facebook for spending
$2,000,000,000,
but to essentially say that vr is not
going to get anywhere in its current
state and to give up a sort of a way to
prototype applications without
necessarily investing in a vr headset
is,
that's,
that's the objective of this.
I mean the,
the games on the iphone didn't kill
playstation one or for whatever the fuck
it or kill it.
But the rumor is these are the last of
the consoles really the last for,
for example,
the three 60 and the playstation three
lasted for a decade.
Yeah.
But the,
the experience of like,
I just got an xbox one recently.
He played that ufc game.
No,
I haven't played it yet.
I think you and I should do one.
One,
one,
one versus one.
You'll get a shit ton of views.
Yeah,
that'll be fun.
definitely do that.
I narrated it.
So it'd be weird playing with my own
voice saying I'm right.
That's true.
Narrate.
Yeah,
I forgot about that.
That'd be extra cool.
That shit took forever.
I had to narrate all of the specific
movements.
Specific combinations came out well
though.
Oh,
they know what they're doing,
man,
because was a bad mother.
The old days you boot up like a
basketball game or something and it's
all the cadences off,
you know.
And you can tell where the different
phrases are inserted.
Yours is smooth,
man.
They're bad motherfucker.
They know what they're doing.
And did you go up to vancouver for that?
No,
no,
we did it all in calabasas actually.
Oh really?
Okay.
Yeah,
I know they have a big studio in
vancouver.
They have studios think they rent studio
space here too.
Oh,
okay.
I'm warning the following glitches or
very rarely occur in the game actually
kicks all sorts of ass also.
This isn't actually rogan and goldberg.
Silly.
Oh,
this is tommy to tom or tommy told joe
rogan.
Let me put the volume on.
Impersonation.
Yeah,
it's using glitches from the game.
Good.
Go ahead
and joe connotate,
ufc glitches.
Mikey's pretending to be a turtle that
can't flip over.
He's trying to confuse great beer.
Well,
that was only his feet and he got it.
Here's some great books.
He is not happy about this right now.
Oh,
you know what?
I think they might have no,
no.
Dude,
this kid.
This guy is going to get fucked up.
Oh my god.
Look how bad the glitches freezing your
body.
Well,
one of the advantages is that your
opponent is completely confused,
unsure if you're a real person anymore.
Look how good that call me.
A body move as you can see,
and the ice man,
his back on his feet.
This crowd is going crazy,
joe.
Total disregard for the laws.
This is funny.
Spin take down.
He's been leading those effectively all
night.
Joe gustafson is the guy just flew
through the air.
What are they doing to make a guy do
that?
I want to know what they do.
I mean it's a glitch obviously,
but like what does the combination that
makes the character behave like this?
Gustafson for folks listening to this,
he's flying through the air,
like around and flipping and then
landing on his head and flipping around.
70 foot sliding.
Take them.
Oh,
she's out too.
She's out and liz carmouche doesn't
realize it.
Doesn't know that ronda rousey's out
punching it.
The air.
We'll be looking intensely at the action
tire herself out.
Mike rod.
It needs to be careful not to hit her in
the back of the head.
Answer for this mummy guard.
Yeah.
People listening to this.
You're not gonna get anything out of it,
so just go to ea.
Ufc glitches.
Tommy toehold,
he's a really funny guy.
He does a lot of these videos.
He's got a whole series of them.
Really funny stuff
on most of it on a ufc and mma.
Watch how it ends I think,
and
nothing happens.
It's funny.
So those little glitches.
Not good.
No very upset.
They're upset that you just showed the
actual tough shit because a,
it's not going to keep people from
buying a patch a wave to fix that.
I think that's just funny enough.
Two people go,
wow,
there's a new ufc game out.
Right,
but that's the reason I'm like,
I'm not fully on board with it,
is only because it kind of fucks up or
the relationship between independent
content creators and game developers
because what they do is,
and the reality are,
you're going to take a hard line stance
and then it happened with nintendo.
They fucked up.
They were guys making a career posting
videos about nintendo shit gone complete
career over.
Well,
that's bad on nintendo and nintendo got
shit for it,
but it doesn't change.
It doesn't change the reality.
You know my joke because I couldn't
attach all there that money,
all that advertising youtube money too.
That's extra income now for a nintendo
to be able to put an intender videos up.
Now tendo owns the rights to it,
so they get money off all of these.
There's a real discussion about whose
intellectual property that is that we
just watched.
Did we watch something for me a or did
we watch something from tommy toehold,
toehold.
And he see he doesn't have a product
without them,
right.
He doesn't have a product without them
in this instance.
So they might put a block on that
particular video.
Oh,
why don't they would.
Because the ufc sanctions his show that
like his show.
Cool.
So I'm sure he has some sort of an
arrangement with them.
Yeah.
So I don't think it's going to be an
issue,
like,
go for the record.
I think it's funny as hell and I w I
would totally watch it at all.
I was trying to say is that I've seen,
I have a lot of friends in the gaming
side of youtube and fucking disaster.
Yeah.
Um,
how does that work?
Like when guys are doing comments when
they're commentating on a match,
who owns that?
Like star crash or.
Yeah.
Those are big things,
right?
True.
Yeah.
Podcasts and most of the super
competitive,
uh,
gaming.
The developers are on board with it
because that's the big part of their
community business model,
but generally speaking they're also
involved in the events themselves and
the setup and whatnot,
so they have a more control than an
independent guy in his bedroom or
whatever his office shopping together,
something like that know,
but there are enormous youtubers like
tens of 10 million subscribers,
20 million subscribers,
whatever,
that their whole model is playing games,
other people's intellectual property and
there is no clear guideline yet on
what's considered fair use and what
isn't,
especially when you're commercializing
the content.
Well,
the guys who make create the video
games,
so it would be foolish to try to stop
any sort of an interactive community.
Like that's what we all think.
But again,
you've got some gray hair dudes sitting
in an office that they actually got the
job after blockbuster went under these
motherfuckers and uh,
and you know,
that's,
that's their way of that.
That's the way they behave and that's
not going to change overnight.
Malicious.
How blockbuster went down.
I warned them.
I was on the board.
I told him you got to be careful because
these dvds or on the light and laser
discs that have ruined our market,
it's amazing.
Well,
pretty much everything within the next
couple of years.
I mean,
I,
I have a cd slot that I,
a usb cd slot that I attached to this.
Oh,
external or dvds on.
Never used it once.
Never touched it.
And it made me realize like,
remember when the floppy disk went away
and everybody fucking freaked out.
Like apple said,
no more floppies no.
Well that's the weird thing about
technology.
We were talking earlier about how,
about how about how uh,
these devices are becoming almost a
status symbol.
Having old shit.
People were going to sneer at you.
You rock and old computer and old
district hand somebody a cd.
See what they do.
They get upset.
Go over some chicks house.
She's got some old ass computer.
You're going to be like,
this bitch is crazy ass old ass computer
is.
There's a weird,
there's a weird,
uh,
it's like a tech prejudice.
Do you have an archi?
You'll have an rq park.
You just press that button.
You know,
where they put a piece of tape over that
thing,
folsom tape up,
draw the letter or on it and stick it
over that little button.
Do you,
do you save old tech?
Like I just found my own a dash the
other day.
I was just wanting to have the stats.
I have a dash that's not.
There's a certain age at which I think
it becomes cool again,
kind of like cars.
Like I recently,
uh,
showed my four year old,
the original second genesis and we were
playing streets of rage heat and he
fucking dominating what you said for
that because it gave me that game at
four.
I'd be crying,
you know.
So,
uh,
yeah.
I like to sort of go back and those
origin stories in my childhood and stuff
like that.
Uh,
I did an unboxing video of the original
nes,
nintendo 1985 found going one in mint
condition in the box seat.
People in the comments were telling me
like,
listen,
this brought tears to my eyes,
just swear to god,
but it's not because of the product,
right?
Is that because of the promise?
If you remember being a kid and that nes
being under that christmas tree at that
moment,
if you,
if your dad was a fuck up,
you know your mom was a bitch,
that console
strong words,
that console for a moment guaranteed a
certain number of hours together because
people use the game together.
Like for me and my friend,
for me and my brother,
that's what it was.
The thing is under the tree,
you look at one another,
you're like,
I know what this means.
It's not about the console and,
and this is a huge problem with gaming
now is that it's all online.
Yet the most beautiful shit happens in
real life.
You want to fuck up the guy next to you,
not some dude in who knows where.
Right?
That's why land part is they're so fun.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
High five each other.
I have to fucking do it in my,
in my parents' house,
a main floor upstairs.
And then immediately after the
multiplayer match will be over.
The losing team would run up to where
the winning team wasn't immediately
start fighting,
you know,
whatever.
Goofing around.
Like get pissed,
yell at one another,
go back to another round,
et cetera.
Yeah,
those are fun,
man.
Land parties are fun.
That's so.
It's so true too,
about so many games taking place online
now.
So much of the experiences people not
interacting with other people online.
That's a very different experience than
being in a room.
Like if we set up computers on this
beautiful big ass table,
this would be a great place for India.
A safe place.
This will be the who was land party ever
down.
Definitely mario kart.
We should totally have a fucking party
here down.
I haven't played quake forever.
I bet I suck my ass.
I was never.
I was never that good.
So while I was never good,
but it was good compared to regular
people.
But listen to this elitist talk over
there.
It's true.
Good.
Compared to regular compared to regular
people.
I'll fuck you up compared to like those
real quake players.
Right?
Like those guys always killed me.
Yeah.
Well see this is about like the brands
trying to to own the entire experience.
I want to own not just your money when
you buy the game,
but they want to own everything you do
with that game after the fact.
You take this psychological approach
though,
because I think that it's a very
interesting,
not just the psychological approach to
the reason why people become fanboys,
but particular brands,
but the interactive experience of two
people enjoying the video game together
been like those,
those fight games,
those karate games,
you know,
like mortal kombat duking it out with
each other.
That's half the fun is that you're doing
it with another person.
We used to,
uh,
you know,
get home from school and I mean,
you knew who was good.
The guy who was good was the guy down
the street,
you know,
and it's like,
dude,
beat the game.
Didn't die once,
you know,
it were legends.
Legends were made,
you know,
now it's an anonymous face somewhere
else and everyone's bitching and
complaining online.
You get on xbox live.
It's a disaster.
The thing about those games though is
that they can make the day vanish.
Oh definitely.
They are magic.
You throw those games on your day and oh
look,
you're starving to death and it's three
in the morning.
That happened at world of warcraft.
That baby died more than one.
More than one.
There was a few of them.
It was war.
See those games scare the shit out of
me.
I won't get invested for that reason
too.
I think what's going to happen
though is especially with all the apple
tv's and and like google tvs and stuff
that we're getting going to,
there are going to start taking over the
game market to a point where all our
phones are going to be controllers.
If you have an apple tv you can use.
We could download a angry birds and we
all come over to my house.
We all pull out our phones.
I can hit up your controller app and we
all are applying.
It can already send.
We have apple tv.
You can already send images and video
screen and you could watch it up on a
big screen,
but I'll touch a video.
Ultimately they can't if you.
Unless you're connected,
if,
unless you're tapped in oculus rift
style plugged in,
they can't monetize what's going on
here.
The enjoyment we're having,
they don't want that.
Doesn't do fuck all for them.
Like they intend to wheat.
When it first launched,
it was all about getting together with
friends.
Right.
It didn't even have online gaming I
believe,
and you play sports and people are
goofing around in front of the fucking
tv and dancing and doing whatever it
was.
It was too.
It got to a point and then didn't.
Now nintendo has all kinds of problems
because at first it was like it was
immediately appealing and then it
eventually fizzled out.
It didn't have that same kind of.
Nobody gives a fuck about.
We're never here when.
Exactly.
But in your bedroom it changes
everything.
Yeah.
What happened?
Oh,
you're back to playing.
I took.
I took my wig.
You never used it.
I got the new eu.
Has a nice big controller,
a tablet and stuff.
Never touched it.
Decided fuck it.
I'm going to put in my bedroom tv,
use it for netflix.
Now I can't get enough of it because
it's got a huge screen,
so you're scrolling through netflix,
surfing the net,
and then you watch it on the screen and
you watch on the screen is the perfect
bedroom pool video games so better as a
controller than as a video game console.
It kind of is,
but,
but it's,
it's just great because your controller
is like,
it's like having an ipad and you're
searching for videos on netflix or stuff
like that,
which is way better than using your
remote control.
The fund,
the r dot,
o dot s and when you're trying to find
the name of a movie that is annoying as
fuck that you can't just go like that
and put apocalypse now,
you know.
Um,
what do you think about the microsoft
version of that,
of the xbox,
that connect?
Is that what it's called?
What is it called?
Connect.
Yeah.
And it's like a video thing to camera
sees your body move.
How is that not ready for prime time?
Oh,
it works.
You don't look excited.
That's great.
There was a huge controversy with it
over them having it all be always on,
right,
so they could watch fuck on the couch.
So I don't do,
we came,
we seem to keep coming back to that
welcome to the podcast,
but we're immature.
Perfect spot.
Um,
so there was a big controversy at first
that,
that nobody wanted it and they were
including the names then it was going to
be always on and then,
and then it was gonna be expensive and
all that shit.
And,
and the reason I think people don't want
it is because like an xbox buyer,
you've got to look at the core
demographic of who's going to get an
xbox.
The minute it comes out it's,
it's,
there's a certain sex in a certain age
group,
et cetera,
that,
that stuff is popular with and they want
to run around shooting people online
essentially the vast majority or play
sports games,
whatever it is.
And there's just only so much you can do
right now in terms of emotion game.
I do I want to do dance dance
revolution.
Yes.
Do I want to.
Do people learn martial arts on those
things?
It's striking.
Martial arts could learn.
That's the joe rogan game,
the fitness apps joe,
or some of the best things about the
connect because it reads your body and
so like if you're doing like some kind
of hard workout that they have available
using xbox fitness,
it will tell you if you're not bending
your arms,
right?
Yeah,
and your arms,
big drums and it tracks how much
calories,
so I want you to do that with martial
arts techniques.
Yeah.
He goes,
no,
no.
Not somebody with his credibility.
No,
no.
That would be something that would be
really beneficial to someone learning
martial arts techniques because most of
the striking techniques,
whether it's a striking with your hands
or with your feet,
knees and elbows,
you're learning them in the air before
you ever strike things as like a
beginner sort of not even just as a
beginner,
like one of the most important things
when I teach people a kicks,
specific kicks is practicing them in
there because if you're constantly
relying on hitting something to maintain
your balance and to maintain the
distribution of your weight,
you bounce off of things and you'll.
You'll rely on those things if you don't
penetrate them enough and one of the
keys to learning how to kick correctly
is actually learning how to kick in the
air.
It's also controlling the dexterity of
your legs because you're not relying on
anything to stop the momentum of your
shot.
You have to tighten up your entire body
on on the extension of the kick or the
punch.
And so in doing so,
you actually strengthened the tendons
and if you're doing it correctly,
you develop more dexterity,
more dexterity.
When you're throwing kicks your ability,
there was always a thing in
demonstrations.
Um,
my instructor,
when I was a kid,
uh,
jay hahn,
kim will do these,
do these really impressive
demonstrations where they would throw
kicks at your face,
like you would stand there and they
would stop them like right here,
like,
stop at all.
We would all do that and demonstrate.
Right,
right,
right.
Michael o'malley,
who's another one of my instructors
who's this incredible,
a taekwondo black belt,
multiple times national champion,
and he's a big tall guy and he would
throw these insanely impressive kicks,
like half an inch from your face.
Just we'll kicks where the toad just,
just he knew because he threw so many
kicks in the air,
he knew where objects,
where he knew how to stop.
So you developed this dexterity so you
could use that.
The teaching is correctly.
All you would essentially need is an
open area where you could extend your
left,
but I was just about to say is that how
many people are going to put their foot
through their tv on?
There's actually actually two
games that I know of.
It's one's called ufc trainer,
which is a game that does,
does that,
it teaches you different ufc moves,
but there's a new ronda rousey one also
that,
uh,
that you just does that pretty much
does.
It uses your connect and it,
it teaches you different moves.
Kick to the balls.
Kids
kick the balls when you're ready.
Go and kick you out.
This is ridiculous guys.
The fuck can you do.
Can you do a.
Okay.
I just want to identify something.
As you had that video up,
did anybody notice the physique of the
two guys playing the average video game
player?
Like,
here's your problem.
Have you ever seen the magic?
The gathering photo with a dude went to
a magic the gathering place and took
pictures of everybody's asked cracks,
you know,
like giving a thumbs up front of all
these different ass cracks like,
and you know,
that's what I'm getting at though with
the connect is it's like for guys that
are really into that thing,
you don't have a problem getting out of
the house anyway.
You know what I mean?
It's like this is their god damn.
People move their bodies.
That's right.
Exactly.
So I don't know.
I don't know if motion gaming will ever
be will ever be a big thing or if it is
a big thing,
it's going to be so far down the road
that it's just so immersive.
So amazing.
I like it more for skype.
I like it more for like different
applications connect game.
It's so cool.
Being able to skype with like I could
call you on my xbox called joe rogan and
video skype with you and you're on my
projector screen.
It's pretty goddamn science fiction shit
right there.
And that was pretty dope.
Do you ever do that on the road?
Do you ever bring a laptop on the road
and html to the tv and skype through the
tv and.
Yeah.
Uh,
I know I was at the airport the other
day and some kid was bringing this
console console the whole deal.
Controllers,
games.
Do that suitcase opened it up.
Do that.
I mean,
to be honest,
I'm not that addicted.
I feel like this whole process of doing
what I do has actually desensitizes me
in a way to a lot of this stuff.
Like I think I was in in some ways more
of a fanatic before then.
Now that make any sense.
How come you're jaded?
Maybe you don't see my kids.
No,
I'm not.
Maybe you're just normalized.
What it is is it's like so much for a
lot of people.
Like I said,
these devices are really important to
them.
You get,
they get some new thing that's like a
super highlight,
et cetera.
Of course you're going to be
psychologically impacted when companies
are just sending you fucking everything.
[inaudible] how can it not?
It affects you get everything for free.
Everything.
do you get to keep?
No,
not everything.
I shouldn't say everything.
You get to keep them and this and this.
I don't.
You have to pay for your laptop.
That's apples.
Apple won't give you shit really ever.
Well,
why don't you use something that's.
You said.
If you say there's all these windows
computers that are grades,
just the user experience was not as good
when he loves windows.
Joe,
interesting windows.
I'm interested.
No,
I'm not.
I'm not paid by an ied between the line.
I think for yourselves,
ladies and gentlemen,
you hear this clearly as I.
Let me put it this way.
Pretty much that the vast majority of
people in my business on youtube,
I know them all personally use apple
computers.
Yeah.
It's kind of universal amongst anybody
who has enough money to buy an apple
computer.
Dell pc people are going to fucking not
like you saying that.
Listen,
I'm sorry,
folks tried windows aids,
dark shit.
Tried windows seven diggity diggity dog.
There's a reason why apple is,
is the company they are and microsoft is
a company there.
That's,
that's the way I like to say it.
We used alienware for the podcast for a
while,
which makes fucking awesome computers.
We use it for the podcast for awhile
because they were sponsoring us,
so they gave us some free computers and
and I liked that.
They sponsor fighters too,
so I wanted to do.
Right?
Yeah.
They have quite a few little guy.
Mighty mouse.
Yeah.
He makes his johnson.
Oh no,
no,
he's not.
Sorry.
He's got a big sponsor though.
Oh,
xbox.
Yes,
he does.
Last box.
Yeah,
but a lot of guys had been sponsored so
we,
we really.
The computers are incredible.
I mean and they are as far as like high
end laptops,
like for gaming.
They're monstrous.
Definitely.
But I didn't like the interface.
The windows notifications kept popping
up.
All these different.
The notification is driving me fucking
crazy.
That shit was ridiculous.
This is a clunky operating system.
You guys are clunkers.
It's true,
man.
They the gates too busy chasing pussy.
that's what he's doing.
Yeah,
he doing coke.
He's flying,
flying around his private fucking
spacecraft.
Allegedly.
Allegedly because tooling around fucking
harbor and his boat.
Microsoft does,
does some good things like the xbox.
It's a success.
The xbox is success.
Why?
If microsoft is so god damn popular,
why if microsoft is so immersive,
microsoft's prop problem is that they're
so damn popular.
That's it.
They had to fucking hold on to vintage
retro stuff for so long because
otherwise they would give up a
percentage of the mark.
God forbid somebody can't type a word
document or open their excel spreadsheet
from 1997.
that's really what held them back.
I think it's a part of it.
I mean,
how do they hold them back in the user
interface though?
Because when they put out,
when they put out windows a seven,
they put this new.
Was it seven or eight?
No,
sorry,
windows eight new ui,
which they didn't really want to give a
name,
but uh,
it was essentially a touch based ui that
it was a huge overhaul,
right?
Where now they wanted one platform to
work on tablets,
laptops,
desktops,
etc.
People freaked out.
People were like,
how am I going to do this?
A,
b,
c,
d,
because of the market penetration of the
old ostp windows seven and xp before
that.
So on and so forth.
The voice of the people that their old
customers was louder than that of the
new customers.
They didn't have yet much like the
automakers in,
in,
you know,
the domestic automakers I think had the
same problem here.
Your user base gets so big that your
user base gets so big that you're more
worried about pissing them off.
Then you are about attracting new
people.
Wow,
that's weird.
It is.
They have to take those things into
consideration when they,
when they innovate,
they have to pull back all the time,
but if you think about it,
you don't want ever bought a mac book
because they were worried about
microsoft word.
It's true.
That's the key is you bought a macbook
because it was a tool,
just a platform and essentially like
when you deal with things like
documents,
spreadsheets,
you know,
dot doc things almost anything can open
those now.
It's not just microsoft word.
Exactly,
and that's their problem,
is that what the exclusivity that they
had for so long,
he's not really that important anymore.
It doesn't make any sense.
Once upon a time it was,
but now,
I mean google has everything.
You do everything in the cloud.
Google docs does everything.
I haven't.
I haven't touched a microsoft product in
a very long time in terms of software,
which brings me to those google laptops.
How do you feel about those chromebooks?
Do you like them?
I love them.
Well,
you fuck with them.
I think it's.
It's the perfect finally price point to
be able to give somebody like your mom a
laptop and have her do exactly what she
wants to do with no extra bullshit.
Like my mom just probably wants to just
surf the net.
Maybe look at some photos,
watched some netflix and that's all
she's really probably going to do to the
max.
She's not going to be editing videos and
if she desert,
I'm sure there's an app that she can
actually do it at if she wanted to.
The problem is a lot of people
saying with chromebooks is why aren't
chromebooks just android books,
right.
Is enormous ecosystem of apps available
on android.
Is it because of the fact that chrome is
their browser and they're trying to.
Chrome is their browser.
Make the leader.
It's the girl,
is it?
Yup.
Wow.
By,
by far too crazy.
They beat out microsoft internet
everywhere.
ASk people who ask the average person
how they feel about google in general.
You know,
and everyone always thinks it's a
positive brand.
Ask them how they feel about microsoft
and it's a completely different.
So maybe there's some,
some,
some public relations issues.
I don't know exactly what he got fucked
up there,
but google appears like this company
that's giving us all this great shit and
not asking for anything because what
they're asking for is fucking way deeper
than that.
Yeah.
They're asking for connection with you.
They're asking for you.
they're asking for.
Yeah.
they're immersing themselves in your
world and to control.
They want more than your wallet.
Google and microsoft and apple and
everybody else.
Remember that song?
we want your soul.
You are dead.
Your house is it?
oh wait,
no,
no.
Somebody else.
anyway,
cool song.
But essentially about that.
This immersive connection.
Yep.
Do you think that microsoft fucked up
because they were a part of.
They were essentially one of the very
first like portals into this new world.
Yeah,
like using windows and this world of
technology,
but now there's new world has kind of
emerged from the people who grew up in
the internet and they grew up with the
accountability of forums of social
media.
I take it as a given that this,
this accountability has sort of shaped
the way they do business were,
which is what I've been saying for a
long time is what gives me hope because
I think the smartest,
most innovative,
most progressive people in,
in terms of technology and innovation
also are very ethical.
Right?
It's,
it seems to be a part of the whole
package.
Like you don't hear about evil,
big new tech companies.
You hear about companies like google
companies that are trying to do things
correctly.
That there were a couple of protests at
google io.
Of course they're a,
they recently acquired a boston
dynamics.
Yeah.
They make robots.
You make pretty fucking gnarly robots
are robots pro and so,
um,
they also,
some of their technology goes into some
of those drones doing that activity out.
Well,
how about artificial intelligence as
well?
I mean,
they also have kurzweil on board who
wants to make people turn into fucking
computers.
So The overlords.
I don't honestly don't be scared.
I feel like super technologically
advanced people are insanely secular.
I don't know where their moral compass
is.
I think they get off on control really.
In what way?
Well,
this.
Look at google's ecosystem for example,
or even apple's.
Okay.
Everywhere you go.
The objective of one product is to get
you to buy the next one.
Is it though is the objective of their
products?
Let's talk about google maps.
Google.
Google is an advertising company and
it's funny that I'm talking about them
because in a sense that employee,
the both of us,
we both post shit on youtube and yeah,
I'm a big fan since monday and I love.
I have a unique insight as well because
a good friend works there.
Yeah.
At a very high level.
My friends worked there too and it's.
I'm not trying to say anything negative
about it,
but.
No,
I know you're not.
But the model is such that for us to get
the most out of technology,
we technology has to get the most out of
us.
Yeah.
But isn't that just a side effect of the
immersion?
sure.
I mean,
I don'T think that's what I said.
It's not negative or positive,
it's just is.
But that's what we're talking about
today about your phone preemptively
knowing how far you are from work
because you're going to work and it's
right.
We always look at the negatives,
but the positives of that,
let's go back to the porsche or let's go
back to the muscle car.
That there will always be individuals
that liked it better the way it was
before.
Yes,
but the good thing is you can have both,
but you can't.
With phones,
you can't.
Some do.
Do they go back to the flip phone?
We sell them on ting tang.
So they sold the beautiful fucking
shitty button phones.
My guess would be that that's not an
expanding market.
Dana white,
he fucking uses one of those all the
time.
That's how he does all his texting.
Whenever you do appreciate you telling
that to everybody.
He loves it.
He jokes about it.
He takes.
I have pictures of him holding up his
phone.
He um,
he can do it at a dinner.
He could be at dinner and he's so good
with his thumb.
[inaudible] he can be underneath the
table texting you.
That's a very bizarre use case scenario
I liked.
I really like it.
He's a real wizard with it.
So I've had him show me.
He's done it before where he'll,
he'll go,
he'll look at his phone real quick and
then he puts it out because he gets it
onto my number and he puts it under the
table and just.
And then all of a sudden,
my thing,
dude,
I'm texting you right now and I'm like,
this is crazy.
He does it all with his thumb because
it's thumb is so educated as to where
like three presses to get an s.
That's right.
Doing all that shit.
Nine.
yeah.
He's doing all that shit.
That's ridiculous.
That's a skill he doesn't want to give
up.
You know,
he's got to stick with it.
It is a skill.
I was reading this thing the other day
about typing and handwriting recognition
and one of the things that they were
talking about was shorthand.
Is that like,
people forget that short really writing
thing.
Yes.
Gregg shorthand.
I think it's called.
I forget the,
it's like really old technology from the
18 hundreds.
Oh wow.
The,
the implementation of it when they first
started using it and like what things
stand for,
what vowels and what things.
And you could write hundreds of words
per minute in shorthand faster than you
could ever fucking type.
Wow.
Yeah.
But it never took off.
Well it did.
It just took off for people didn't have
computers and once people develop
typewriters and computers,
there's a new pen that they have that
uh,
I haven't,
I,
I ordered it just to see like what the
fuck the technology was like.
Oh,
one of those scribe pens.
It.
Yes.
This is what it does.
It doesn't just know this is what it
does as you're writing,
it takes a photograph of your notes.
Cool.
It also transcribes and audio,
like if there's an audio recording
capability.
So say if you.
And I were talking,
I was doing an interview with you and I
was asking you about all these different
things and I was writing down my notes,
it would take photos of the notes and it
would take photos of the notes and
correspond those notes to the audio
recording.
So if I said at that time has come,
no biggest dick is right.
And then like I would click on that and
then it would go back to the
conversation where You were talking
about women always being in pain when
you have sex.
Like,
oh yeah,
that's why,
you know.
So for students,
a student lecture,
whatever that perfect example,
perfect example,
as long as it didn't lecture was clear
enough.
You didn't take in too much extraneous
noise.
Yeah,
they were close to the actual yes or
whatever.
But what a great idea.
I mean,
I,
I think I should pull up the,
uh,
the name of it just in case I've heard
of them.
I've never tried it.
One,
I'd like to have the old one where you
just had a little memory card and it
just remembered what you wrote.
And I just never really does he,
does this translate the written word
into a digital form?
That's a very good question.
Icd,
I think.
I think it did back.
I don't,
I never really played with it too much,
but I know like a lot of things can do
that now with most scanners.
it's called a live scribe guy.
Why fly pen?
It's really interesting,
man.
I'm really curious to try this thing
out.
I mean,
I wish almost that I was a reporter will
report on it when you get hit much work.
But um,
the,
the idea behind it is quite fascinating
and I love that.
I,
I had read something about shorthand and
that's where,
uh,
it,
yeah,
these guys have been around for a bit,
but this is obviously a new product.
Yes.
Yeah.
Shorthand is fucking interesting,
man.
It's interesting.
Yeah,
it is gregg shorthand.
That's what it's called,
named after the inventor who's named
john robert.
Greg,
system of penn stenography that gained
popularity,
popularity in the early 20th century.
But it was a crate created a long
fucking time ago.
No kidding.
No.
Um,
but I love the idea that this pen
records an audio of us having a
conversation and then like I should use
it for podcasts.
That's really what I think I might
actually use it because I have stacks of
these things sometimes that I go over
like these nodes during shows.
Shit,
I feel like I'm underperforming you only
I don't think you took like one note so
far today.
Well,
it's really usually things that I wanted
to talk about that I forgot or that I
knew I was going to look that or didn't
want to forget or an idea that I had
while it was happening because I don't
remember half of these fucking things.
Nigerian gay marriage.
Okay.
What the fuck does that mean?
The world's end herbie's infected monkey
in Florida?
Uh,
emotional needs dog.
Some juicy stuff there.
Yeti attenborough.
Colorado floods.
Yeah.
I mean I don't know what half these
fucking things mean what the point was.
But if I had,
if I had written them down with a
corresponding audio recording,
I mean,
then I would really be able to click on
it.
Possibly jr.
The that's when he was talking about
this and I wanted to bring up that
amazing.
Just I love that aspect of uh,
of new technology and apparently it
works on a special type of paper as
well.
Yeah.
I'll find out all about.
I won't do an unboxing,
but I'll,
I'll talk about it on this.
I think you should do.
I think you should do not doing it.
I think you should.
I'll tell you about it and you could do
it.
That's why I have decided to limit
myself as far as how many things I do.
If I don't,
I will just keep doing things true.
And next,
you know,
I'll be a professional racquetball
player or something stupid,
which would be pretty cool.
Take up a lot of time.
Whatever it is that I have,
whatever my disease is,
I know how to manage it.
That's good.
Don't do too many things.
So no unboxing videos?
No,
no,
no.
I'm just joking around what you want to
know.
Something like the origin of unboxing
videos is the everyday guy.
Not in this world.
Yes.
You know,
getting something and giving you his
reaction in some ways you become
sophisticated to a point where you might
not be addressing the things that the
everyday guy is looking to have
addressed.
It's possible,
but essentially you are the everyday
god.
I sTill am the everyday guy but immersed
in this world of technology and a far
deeper level and isn't it the everyday
guys opportunity to listen to that.
Watch those and then I'm on.
I'm on the joe rogan podcast right now.
So you know,
in some ways,
yes you already everyday guy,
but when you start talking to these
brands directly,
things get fucking weird,
but things get weird.
It affects you,
you a does.
It
does.
It doesN't affect us.
I mean it does,
but it doesn't.
It goes men.
And what way did you do,
do you like put on kid gloves for lg?
No,
no,
no.
I just,
I'm having a hard way to.
I'm finding it hard to articulate,
but tech news,
right?
Big tech sites that are out there,
They have a report underneath on a
review,
for example,
the product they're reviewing does a
huge banner ad right above it.
Yeah,
but if they are honest and always
committed to being honest,
I mean that isn't that goddamn essential
for the company themselves.
If you.
If you put out a dud,
I'm sorry,
but you put out a fucking done.
Well you need to do is get rid of those
weak ass engineers and designers to put
out that.
Doug,
if you don't,
your fucking business is gonna.
Go under.
They do do that.
There's a tide coming.
If you've got a shitty foundation,
fucking house is going to get into the
ocean definitely,
but all these tech websites have a floor
full of salespeople in a floor full of
reporters.
Those floor for whoever's the problem.
Then they need to say anybody's a
problem.
I'm saying thrown into the water.
We're not reporting on a murder.
You're reporting on something that
somebody spending a lot of money to try
and sell,
but if it's dog shit,
dog shit.
I agree with that,
but that's not so much of an issue
anymore because this is getting really
iterative.
It's not so much an issue anymore of dog
shit,
dog shit.
It's.
we're talking about a sliver.
In fact,
a popular tech website that I won't name
for a very long time has been running
ties.
They do appoint analysis on devices and
he'd been running ties on the flagship,
a android phones and the iphone.
A tie on a point,
like a decimal point analysis.
How the fuck do they tie?
Exactly.
We'll do.
They tie exactly because they just tie.
Exactly.
No,
they do not because they're doing it
because they don't want to piss people
off.
So you don't believe them.
I don't.
I won't make that leap,
but when I see something like that,
I automatically might.
My mind starts telling me that there's
something more here than meets the eye.
Isn't there an issue also with putting a
quantitative value on a roof?
Oh,
most dedicated five stalls,
four and a half star,
so I'm talking like eight point three
decimal point analysis.
What we saw that about the ufc game when
you were watching that connect ufc game,
it was like six point five and it's
review.
That's right.
Because those exist because people want
to be told what to buy.
They don't want to do the work and I'm
not hating on the audience.
Everybody's busy as fuck.
You know,
if you can tune in and find out what the
best shit is in five minutes or less,
so be it,
do it.
Yeah.
The problem is that the more you take
your guard down and the more that you
allow for yourself to be programmed to
respond to those things,
the less likely that you're going to be
able to get any kind of accuracy out of
it.
Totally makes sense.
Yeah,
I,
I see what you're saying.
It's certainly opens up the door to that
possibility.
So you've got all these people in the
business calling themselves journalists.
I've always been against it.
I don't think you can be a product
journalists,
but you know,
that's a very interesting situation when
someone's an embedded journalist.
Right.
And what do you mean by embedded?
Well,
you were also in bed with the company
that literally.
Yeah,
yeah.
Got it.
Yeah.
I mean there's an issue with mixed
martial arts and the ufc has had
problems with companies that have been
critical of the ufc and it's damaged the
relationship they have with the,
with the reporters.
But if you're a real reporter and you
have a real opinion that the problem is
when you work for a corporation,
when you're an independent like
yourself,
it is the responsibility of that
independent to be completely objective
because that's what everybody turns to
you for.
And as soon as we can't count on you for
that,
the whole process of having an
independent,
it becomes irrelevant.
it doesn't matter.
You're not an independent.
You might say you're an independence,
but you're an lg fan boy.
There's no doubt that there is no doubt
that the reason channels like mine have
successes because we are third parties
because we are not in any meaningful way
attached to anything.
And because for the most part we look to
be a like,
like everybody else.
Like here we are.
We started a youtube channel,
well anybody could start a youtube
channel,
so the context helps,
helps to support the messaging in a way,
but the problem is that the further
along this path you go,
the more important you become and the
and the treatment changes,
you know,
it's like if you were walking,
it's like a.
If you're a really good looking person,
lets me bitch to future rogan and you're
walking around.
Yeah,
you know what?
Fuck it.
Let's use joe rogan as an example.
So just brian red band,
too late,
sexy face.
If you're walking around,
you get a certain kind of treatment and
that treatment that you get develops
character.
You can't help it.
So like hot women,
hot women,
women grow.
They have a certain amount of worth that
they attached to themselves because they
are everywhere they go.
They treated like,
like royal hate him for it.
That's the world.
We're a product of the environment.
Right?
And I can't pretend that I am not a
product of the environment that I have
to exist within.
Well,
I just have specIfic rules that I.
When I,
when I engage in,
in,
in my environments where I have
privileges,
I have very specific.
Okay,
let's hear about it.
like martial arts,
it's a huge one because the ufc that I
work for is the biggest,
greatest mixed martial arts organization
ever.
However,
along the way,
during the time that I've been employed
with them over the past 12 years,
there have been instances where I've
actively promoted fighters that were in
other organizations really because I
liked them because I liked him because I
think they're really good and they
didn't have to be honest,
but they didn't pay you anything.
Not a fucking penny.
Right,
okay.
Because I have to be honest,
when fate or amelia danko was in pride,
he was one of the best heavyweights in
the world.
I constantly,
we talk about him on broadcasts to the
point where like some people didn't like
it and some people thought it was like
not smart.
Not over there,
but it is smArt.
You know why it's smart?
Because I have to be honest,
if there's some guy out there that's
murdering motherfuckers and some other
organization and I pretend that the guys
that we have and the only guys that I
want to see fight,
then that's ridiculous that I'm a
ridiculous person and I don't deserve
that position.
I completely agree with you.
So in that same vein,
isn't it the case with tech reporting
like.
Yes,
you do get a very privileged position.
Lg center,
they you,
they're sexy new watch and you're
getting all this.
Let me explain.
Let me,
let me give you an example of this.
This phone,
the most popular single device on the
planet.
You paid for it.
Yes,
but this phone,
this phone specifically is,
it's,
it's probably the best way to do an
analysis of the entire market because of
how popular it is and because of how
important it is as a piece of news,
iphone,
iphone five s with little thumbprint
thing,
you can use your dick for as well.
Yes,
I did this.
You did.
And you could spoof it and you could
spoof it with a little bit of wax.
But anyway,
who fit?
Yeah,
hack it.
So chop off somebody's finger and use in
april battery or you could do that.
Yeah,
eight volt battery.
I think if you catch a person sleeping
and dip their finger in hot wax,
that will do the job to.
Yeah.
You don't have to chop terrible level.
This device.
This device moves the needle.
The reason apple doesn't spend as much
money on marketing and samsung because
they don't have to.
This phone comes out.
It's on the cover in the New York times
has done.
Why is that?
Well,
it's the best because there's a couple
of reasons though.
It's actually,
it's actually not that easy.
When they are about to launch a new
device.
They give this out to people.
They sent it to.
Apple does send stuff to people.
Read that to me,
but to come out to you,
oh god knows.
I picked some south american traditional
media people fucking business week.
That kind of shit.
Exactly.
Wall street journal.
Bingo.
Some fucking crook over there.
You got it.
Let me tell you how it works.
You.
Oh,
I just noticed that was shot in toronto,
that jimi hendrix pictures.
oh yeah,
man.
Got arrested for heroin down there on.
Um,
okay.
So a very selective group of people gets
this device,
then they maintain something,
uh,
beside it called the black list.
And black list is people who are never
going to get the device for one reason
or another.
There are many ways to get on that list.
Are you blacklisted?
No,
there's no public record of the black
list,
but it's just a black list.
Everyone in business knows that it
exists.
I want to do a fucking documentary on
this by the way,
because nobody would watch it except you
and your friend that review shit.
no,
because apple,
apple is a giant.
Like apple affects our lives in ways
everyone's life in a way that might not
be or I might not be articulating.
But um,
so how does that process work?
How do they decide who gets that device?
Well,
you would assume that the people with
the biggest audiences maybe would get it
or maybe just
send it to anybody who wants to talk
about it.
You'd think all the exposure would be
good,
right?
Well why is it that when this device
launched like 15 motherfuckers got it
worldwide,
like a super limited number in inner
circle of reporters because they can
count on those people to only give
glowing reviews and if those people
working for whoever decide that they're
going to write something different
guests where they can find their new
home to blacklist some motherfucking
black.
Yeah,
but that's their fault.
Whose fault?
Their fault really,
because the reason that newspapers doors
are open is because of the fucking
device.
The coverage sells the ads.
The reason why newspapers doors is open
while they're barely fucking burned to
the ground,
great fires,
but truthfully,
it's not just the newspapers.
There's big tech sites that get them as
well,
I'm sure.
Yeah,
so there's a.
There is a group that gets it,
but the problem is you have this fear,
this inherent fear that if you don't do
what the controlling party says to do,
you don't get that access to the device
anymore and unfortunately it's the
access to the device that drives the
trafficking.
Because if you get this review up a week
before anyone else gets what happens to
everybody else's reviews,
what happens to the value of them dips,
because the majority of the purchasing
and purchasing decisions are made based
on the very initial reviews.
But how much value is there in a high
traffic site these days?
Big massive values.
Fucking you.
So a site like,
like ars technica.
Is that a high traffic one?
Yeah,
that's a big one.
Diverge is with the verge verge.
So a guy who writes for one of those is
going to get access.
Let me say,
let me put it this.
Let me.
Let me say this like this.
If you're a reporter working at the
verge and you get the task of doing the
new iphone,
and listen,
I am not fucking attacking to verge.
The Iphone is a great phone call,
arguably the best phone in the market
and nobody really comes out and says,
shit that's untrue about it.
I'm just talking about a potential that
exists that steers in a direction
outside way outside the world of
journalism.
That doesn't happen when somebody is
murdered or you're investigating a crime
or you're whatever it is that
investigative journalism is when the
story is something that somebody else
controls and dishes to only certain
parties.
There's behavioral patterns that exist
because of that relationship of course,
and there's also behavioral patterns
that exist in it being financially
beneficial for you to support certain
companies.
That's what I was saying,
and this is also the psychological
aspect of knowing that you're on this
elite list of 15 journalists that are
going to receive a new phone that's
going to be like,
look at.
You can't write that.
do you think guys?
Right,
like really scathing reviews and then
like park them aside and go,
ha ha ha,
that was just for fun.
LeT's suck some dick.
Definitely.
There's guys,
there's guys that have written stories
after the fact,
after they've been blacklisted,
uh,
about blending the,
explaining what happened.
And I getting a device anymore.
And the problem,
the verge for example,
has record page views.
The days these,
these devices launch record page views
I'm sure.
So they have to,
they have to have it early.
They have to can't the door,
like literally people are employed on
that paycheck.
You're seeing a percentage that came
from that fucking report from having
access to that product.
BuT if you get one,
like if how much difference would it
make if you get one of the day comes out
like when everybody is just what I do,
which is wait in line like a fucking
idiot who could junior old school you
have to but for this,
for this stuff.
The other stuff I get,
I get early now and the other brands do
it.
They like fuck it,
let's get this shit out there.
You know,
apple fuck note.
Their pr team is like,
I'm definitely blacklisted after this
podcast.
So are you this podcast?
Yeah.
Why I'm using.
We're both using apple products.
I'm the phones both.
Both have.
it doesn't matter because I've even
brought up the notion.
The notion is enough.
That's by the apple.
Engineers write me all the time.
They love listening to this show.
I think we have like this weird shit.
Fuck up.
I just fucked it all up.
or everybody.
I love the shit.
I love the shit,
I love the stuff they're making all the
rest of it.
I'm just talking about people prancing
around calling themselves journalists
when that's not the reality.
It's not an open access story.
It's not like some shit went down in
some foreign country and you and another
guy both have the same opportunity to go
there and investigated.
This is way different.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
I absolutely see what you're saying and
when there such a large financial
benefit to having early access,
especially when you look at page views
and things along those lines.
I mean when an iphone comes out you have
essentially 24 to 48 hours where people
were really freaking out.
RIght.
And during that time that you can
accumulate millions and millions of
hits.
Right?
Oh,
it's tricky shit man.
But if everybody did it ethically,
you see with the iphones,
iphone maybe a bad example because it's
such a stellar product and it's really
an a uniquely couldn't controlled
situation,
which is what we were talking about
earlier,
which is their whole argument like,
look what we've done.
Like the reason why we have this
controlled environment is that we put
together the hardware we put together
the operating system,
we make everything compatible,
uses nothing that fucks up.
Right,
but why?
But why are they sending out 15 units if
they know their shit is bad ass because
you're tired of your bullshit,
bro.
Tardy fucking snarky comments.
They are there because they deep down
they are fucking masterminds that
controlling public relations.
Yeah.
Mastermind climate.
Any different with tim cook as opposed
to a steve jobs fanboy alert.
I know.
Who's the ceo of apple?
That's pretty good.
Uh,
I don't know that I can accurately
answer that.
I don't.
I think people always say that's under
steve's influence.
They had product,
got guidelines,
forecasts for way,
way after his death.
So I think they're probably still
executing on stuff that he had in the
pipeline.
What a fucking maniac.
That guy was definitely.
I know there was an article at some
billionaire investor guy dumped all his
apple stock after you read the biography
because he said steve jobs as an
asshole.
Oh,
probably swipe.
Dumped it.
I should pull that up is because it's a
fascinating story.
I think it's pretty hard to manage a
company of that stature and not be an
asshole.
Also,
you gotta think about what is an average
person's life and average person's life
is you have a job,
but you also have like a fucking family
and a lot of other shit you do.
Your job is not your whole life.
No.
To steve jobs.
Apple was his whole fucking life and his
personal life suffered because of it.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Well,
that's probably had something to do with
his health as well.
Probably no investor drop dumps.
Apple stock.
I need to get one of these nexus phones
now.
Now I can't stop thinking that.
I may never have ever used the actual
fucking operating dude.
You can find clips of the even newer
one.
They're calling it l.
I saw the saw the dude.
it looks so beautiful.
Just the way they're looking at design
and working with dimensions up and down.
Now is the next.
Uh,
is that five?
This is fine.
Yeah,
it's the nexus five.
They only one that does that or this,
somebody like sony or somebody running
four point four percent for it now is
just the nexus will always get updates
first because it doesn't have to come
through the carrier.
This isn't unlock device.
Completely open.
Oh,
is it?
This guy's name was julian robertson.
He's number five.
Oh,
three on forbes billionaire list and cnn
reported monday.
This is while ago.
this was way back in 2013 and october,
right after the book came out that the
guy,
this hedge fund investor sold all of his
shares in apple because he's read the
biography of steve jobs and uh,
decided that apple,
the founder of apple was a really awful
person.
He admits this stock did very well for
him,
but he would rather let someone else
make the money from now on.
So the cnn investment show,
closing bell,
see even that I'm off.
I'm always skeptical of that whole.
That's crazy though.
He's saying it caused a crisis of
consciousness.
Yeah.
Wow.
A guy who's worth billions saying
anything it says,
I came to the conclusion that it was
unlikely that a man as really awful as I
think steve jobs was,
could possibly create a great company
for the long term.
I just don't believe that bad guys do
well in the long run.
Well,
who fucking wrote that book though?
You know?
How does he.
I mean,
how well does he know steve jobs?
obviously you can decide to paint us a
show.
You don't know your best friend all the
time.
You know him when you're hanging around
with true.
There's a lot of times when people are
alone like to paint a portrait of steve
jobs without a deeply intimate
relationship with him.
I think you could go all sorts of ways.
You could go the way of these 15
companies that their apple phones in
advance and paint this really glowing,
glamorous picture,
or you could just paint some picture
that you think is going to sell a lot of
fucking books.
Scathing,
awful depiction of.
It's like you ever watch a historical
depiction,
like a historical documentary like,
like lincoln received the show.
No,
the problem is,
you know,
those people didn't really say that.
Oh,
right,
right.
You know,
you know,
they dIdn't say that in that arthur
reenacted or so when you have like a
book on steve jobs,
life mean you have some vague facts that
you don't maybe know the tire
circumstAnces,
the context of the conversations.
It's like you're,
you're,
you're flavoring things.
You have facts you can't,
and then you're throwing those flat
facts in and pouring your own colors on
them and your own shapes to paint your
own picture.
I,
I sort of wonder though.
Okay,
getting back,
getting back to the asshole comment,
like in the movies and stuff as well.
He'll come in and fire somebody in front
of everyone else.
Oh,
wait a minute.
This guy's an idiot because listen to
the rest of his quote.
an interesting twist of logic.
Robertson also said that a steve jobs
was still alive.
He'd still be an apple investor.
Oh,
and then he said,
after watching the ashton kutcher movie,
he thought steve jobs was sexy as though
you didn't say that.
It's not even steve jobs is.
Ashton kutcher says,
no question in that.
He's the man who killed three and a half
men.
What does that?
Two and a half years,
they're all fucking crazy.
I was a billionaire.
I wouldn't do any interviews.
I just be bawling.
I just be flying around in spaceships
and throwing champagne of people.
Why would you even do interviews?
Like I sold my apple stock fall 90
fucking old.
The objective there is to influence the
market.
That's it.
That's what he's doing.
Yeah,
so that I can go.
When you're that big and you hold that
much stock,
your behavior affects so many things.
He might be hedging.
Well,
we don't know how much stock you had.
No,
no.
He's sold his stock.
We know he's a billionaire.
He.
He probably.
He could afford to influence the market.
This is interesting.
I don't know,
man.
Who knows,
but nobody.
Nobody,
nobody knows.
But it took.
I find the stock market to be a bizarre
place because you're talking about the
evaluatIon of a company and it's
impacted by confidence.
That's a fucking ski to ridiculous
scheme.
So one of the weirdest methods of
controlling an economy ever.
It's bizarre.
The idea that it's actually what we rely
on.
Yep.
That's confidence games that like those
things have stock,
those fucking those movies of wall
street where people are on the floor and
like that's the underlying system that
keeps foundation on your table and your
mortgage paid roof over your head.
Goofy antics.
Shit's so crazy and that's that some
archaic shit that may be worked out with
something like bitcoin that like when
digital currency starts taking over,
we have a sort of a different idea of a
monetized value
because of digital currency.
It could.
That could be something that eventually
gets reworked as well.
For sure.
I,
I mean you have to worry about the
financial companies getting a hold of it
and we'll do it.
Do you think that that in that sense
that that's one of the reasons why
transparency is a good idea because
people who are,
who do have ulterior motives and obvious
bad attentions,
financial intentions and bad social
consequences of transparency to like to
what degree will transfer?
That's a good question because I,
because because you were mentioning
earlier that you are transparent.
I'm saying I'm transparent,
but again,
I don't necessarily share everything
about,
you know,
I don't know.
There's a level of transparency that
makes sense and then at some point it
gets weird,
right?
Like if a financial,
a finance guy had to,
if we were able to grasp the amount of
money these fucking guys are making by
trading one inanimate thing for another
anatomy thing,
I don't think society would be very
happy about it.
That's a good point.
You know,
like it's essentially a gambling ring,
like so many of these hedge funds now.
it's not even about investing in a
company you believe in.
It's in making a play.
Well that's one of the reasons why the
bernie madoff situation was so confusing
because I was like,
oh my god,
like this guy,
he was involved in,
you know,
people that were incredibly rich and he
was moving their money and he was doing
it in full view of the world.
It wasn't like he had a huge business
building a whole floor man.
I mean,
you watch them move money around and all
these billionaires and millionaires were
investing with him and he did it in
front of everybody.
That's right.
That,
that exposes the entire system.
What about the crash?
Yeah.
What about the bailout?
What about the bail?
Yeah,
I mean that was in front of all of us,
so it's all so crazy.
It's also crazy and I think that like
the news,
like the evening news,
like a lot of things we're dealing with
dinosaurs.
We're dealing with these forgotten
relics or,
or not forgotten,
but current relics,
young of an age where they're not
relevant anymore.
It's just there.
The ideas behind them that make them
aren't relevant.
Nope.
And they've also been compromised to a
point where they're so unstable when it
comes to things like the stock market.
When you look at derivatives and I tried
to,
peter schIff,
try to explain to riveting to me and,
and,
and you know,
the how people bet on things failing and
that's what I'm saying there is in that
aspect of the economy and it's so
bewildering that anybody ever let that
happen and it's not about,
it's not about what makes sense.
It's about what you can convince people
that that's the problem.
It's much like a betting line on a
fight.
ufc fight.
It's not,
it's the vegas.
It's not necessarily about you.
I was listening to one of your fight
broadcast.
There were,
you were saying you had a great record
picking winners.
Yeah,
but you will never say it or something
like that,
but I never give predictions.
You don't want to give predictions,
but I would imagine be being who you
are,
that you can fairly accurately predict
winners.
Right.
Over And over again.
Pretty accurate,
but not 100 percent.
There's certain fight,
like here's a perfect example.
Well name one that you got surprised.
oh,
I get surprised all the time.
Okay,
so this weidman,
anderson silva surprised me.
I thought it was going to give him some
troubles,
but I never thought he would win by
knockout in the first round or the
second round.
That fight surprised any.
There's no.
There was no way,
but I guess you don't necessarily need
to be perfect in order to make a lot of
money.
Tj dillashaw,
hanan barao.
There's another one at hidden brown,
one of the best fighters on the planet
or a tj dillashaw dominates him for five
rounds and then head kicks him.
Yeah,
I know.
It's crazy.
So yeah,
it's not a.
It's not a science,
but that being said,
I think you could knock it out of the
park a good enough percentage of the
time to make a killing.
Oh yeah,
man.
If I wanted to bet money on fights every
week,
that's what I'm saying.
Oh,
What could make solar so the law,
the lIne that they draw is based on what
they can sell.
So it's relative to what?
To the bedding that's already occurring.
That's why the line moves,
right?
It's no different in the stock market.
If you can convince people that have
stock is valuable,
guess what?
It's valuable.
Do you think is unethical?
If I bet on fights,
I can't affect the outcome.
if I bet on fights myself,
if I decided to do it right,
don't think so.
Really?
I don't think so.
This is breaking news right now,
joe rogan.
I don't.
I mean I'm not a player player or a
coach.
Then I would think that betting on
fights can be very problematic.
Contact you have contact with the
fighters.
That insider trading that.
I don't know.
I would do it.
You should have your own show on
youtube.
Like who was that guy that got ousted?
He used to be the bedding machine and
football.
Jimmy,
the greek champion.
The greek.
Yeah,
but that was because he was racist,
but he wasn't even racist.
He was just kInd of being accurate about
how they used to breed slaves.
Right,
exactly.
So fucking exactly.
But he had a segment on national tv
about bedding.
That's crazy.
Like people care,
you know,
you don't.
many people would watch a show of you
giving your pics on an upcoming event.
It's too mean.
It's too rude.
How is it rude?
It's rude.
I've been rude before.
Pull up kimbo slice versus seth
prejudice.
Ellie.
I was.
We were in.
This is a perfect example of it.
We were backstage in atlanta.
I was working at the punchline in
atlanta and while we were there it was
when elite ecc was on tv and ken
shamrock was supposed to fight kimbo
slice,
but ken shamrock got cut backstage like
while he's warming up and the doctors
wouldn't let him fight so because it was
going to be on tv.
Seth pictures.
Lee who was on earlier on in the card
already been approved by athletic
commission,
already made weight,
decided to fight kimbo in the main
event.
He had already fought that night?
No.
Oh,
okay.
Approved to fight.
It all happened that day.
I see.
So they rearranged the car that day of
the fight.
They paid the other guy money.
Got a got kimbo to fight.
Seth.
Ellie got it.
And so we're backstage and I found out
about it literally as it was going on.
I was like,
oh my god,
seth petrocelli's gonna.
Fuck him up and then the fight happens
and it literally six seconds of seth
veggies.
Ellie knocks him out and I was like,
see,
I told you where it is.
Play it petro silly,
but is this the fight?
Is this me watching the fight?
This is not me watching the fight.
Pull up the video of me predicting it
because I predicted and we were watching
it backstage as it was happening on the
screen.
it was very mean because I was like,
seth,
pressure is always going to fuck him up,
but I like him.
Oh,
he's a nice guy.
So I felt bad after I said it even
though I was.
Here's the weird thing about fighting
that when it's over,
you're on the ground in bloody.
Here it is.
Oh no,
it's a last minute replacement.
Got to parts of san francisco.
He's gonna.
Fuck him up.
If I'm wrong,
you never see this sitting backstage.
What's wrong with it?
Here we go.
Watch how fast.
I felt bad
about that.
I mean,
I probably shouldn't do I look in that
picture.
Boom.
TattooS,
beard,
look,
sexy.
BeArd.
But I looked very intoxicating.
Well,
you were like,
you were motivated at the time.
I think he was a lIttle more composure
will not only was I motivated,
it was in the moment.
Yeah,
I got offstage quite yet.
Yeah.
It was like,
oh shit.
So I literally had just gotten off stage
and boom,
you're in the dressing room and oh they
haven't fought yet.
And black seth.
So he's gonna find out and then we made
the video.
See if with a little more preparation
you could phrase it in a way that isn't
insulting.
I think.
Well my partner at on it opry is an act
active.
Better undermined.
I heard him,
I heard him betting on one of the fight
broadcast.
Very strong average,
like well into the 80 percent.
At one point in time we were at 90
percent.
We've gone full cards where we are 100
percent correct.
Wow.
Yeah.
He fucking doing this page.
Let me tell you,
if you're 90 percent,
you need to be spending some money.
No,
because I would get addicted.
The problem is this,
one of the reasons why don't gamble on
it.
It's not that I worried it would affect
my commentary because I absolutely would
not let it sit.
I've been accused of being biased
before,
but if I am biased because I enjoy
certain styles,
it's certainly not biased because I want
one person to win.
I juSt think I like when people fIght
effectively in an intelligent way.
I liked that.
I like when people are exciting.
I liked when I have like very specific
things that I like about the sport of
fighting and one of them is I,
I enjoy technique and someone who's a,
a real technician,
a craftsman,
somebody really immerses himself.
It doesn't mean they're going to win.
Like sometimes a fighter was just
stronger,
faster.
Just club someone.
I mean there's fighters.
Fights have been lost where the other
guy was clearly the better fighter,
but he's still lost like right.
A perfect is our nesto.
Hoost fought bob sapp.
It's a weird example because it was in k
one have a huge guy.
Exactly.
And ernesto hoost is one of the greatest
kickboxers of all time,
but bob sapp is beat him twice and it
doesn't make any sense.
it was only because bob sapp is 375
pounds a fucking solid steroids and just
running out.
I'm in donkey kong and I mean if you
watch the fight,
you see ernesto,
who's,
who's this masterful technician,
but he just can't deal.
Pull up some of the viDeo of it because
it's three minutes.
We got three minutes.
Alright.
Probably shouldn't pull the video up.
Then three minuteS left over.
That's it.
Look at three hours and 10 minutes say
dear god.
Now I know why everyone says that at the
end.
Flies.
What the hell he's talking abOut
technology.
We Did.
We did.
Okay.
Talked a lot about technical.
We could definitely do this again
though.
WhEn are you going to be in town again?
I don't know right now.
Come on son.
Come up with a schedule.
I should know.
I could make a reason.
Probably listen.
A lot of fun talking to you though,
man.
I'm really enjoying having me.
We'll definitely do this again for sure.
Follow him online.
Unbox therapy,
a youtube.com/unbox.
Therapy's got a really cool stuff.
Really cool to have you on here and
again we could just go on for days and
days and days,
so we'll have to do this again.
Cool.
For sure.
Oh,
thanks to our sponsor.
Thanks to stamps.com.
Go to stamps.com.
Use the code word j r e and get the $110
bonus offer which includes a digital
scale and up to $55 of free postage
stamps.com.
Use the code word j r e thanks also to
onnit.com.
Go to o n n I t use the codeword rogan
and save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
There are very few tickets left for
tonight at the ice house.
Um,
we are in the little room and joeY diaz.
end dollar rare are in the big room.
It's going to Be a motherfucking
pasadena party bitches tonight.
we got sarah tiana,
brian bread band,
tony hInchcliffe,
greg motherfucking fitzsimmons and me as
well.
Good times.
And it's one of the coolest clubs on the
planet earth.
One of the oldest clubs in north America
today started in 1960.
It's a fucking awesome place.
A lot of good vibes.
all right,
much love.
bye friends.
We'll be back next week.
Crash from the float lab will be here.
Lots of other stuff coming up.
Uh,
talk to you soon and give him a very
long,
long last season.
Bye bye.